- You know how's there's a type of JAV,
and this is only in JAV,
but it's the creepy dude.
(laughter)
- We call it the ugly
bustard, I think in the west.
- It's the ugly bustard.
I've always wanted to
know what are the actors
like in real life?
I've always wanted to know.
(talk over each other)
- It's 50 year old men
looking (talk over each other)
- And they purposely have to act creepy.
- We actually need them in
the industry. (laughter)
(instrumental music)
- Hello and welcome to another episode
of the Trash Taste podcast.
I am your host for today, Gigguk
and with me are my usual cohost, the boys
CDawgVA and The Anime Man.
- We are the boys now.
I guess that's just how it goes.
- Let's just keep it simple from now on.
No more nicknames.
And today we have a very
special guest with us.
We have a Kaho Shibuya.
- Hi, I'm the girl here.
(laughter)
- We got the boys and the girl.
You are our first female guest.
It's nice to have a bit of a mix
instead of just having-
- It's finally nice now
that the only female
on the show isn't (laughter).
We actually have something
nice to look at now.
- Thank you so much.
- But why don't you introduce yourself?
- My name is Kaho Shibuya, as
you introduced me, thank you.
Where should I start?
As Kaho Shibuya, I started
my career as an JAV actress
which JAV means Japanese Adult Video.
(laughter)
(talk over each other)
- It's self explanatory.
- Before that, I was a newspaper reporter
after college and then did a little bit
English teaching really, just teaching
English for kids who
were studying for TOEIC,
that's a Japanese thing again.
I think only Japanese
people care about TOEIC
or AKAN.
- The English proficiency test.
- Yeah.
- I had no idea what that was.
- Known mostly in Japan.
- We don't really have to deal with it,
we know we're proficient hopefully.
- If you'll go on Tinder here.
I think you'll get people being like,
"Hey, I need help with
my TOEIC, by the way.
"You look like you speak English."
- I had no idea what the
English proficiency test was
because I know Japan
have N1, N2 and whatever.
(talk over each other)
I know about the N1's and the N2's.
- You're obviously not gonna hear about it
because you don't need to learn English.
- But I heard that you got
an amazing TOEIC score.
What's your TOEIC score?
- The highest is 990
which is kind of weird.
- It's not 1,000?
- Yeah, it's not 1000.
(talk over each other)
But I take that score.
- So you got a perfect score?
- I nailed it
on that day.
Only on that day.
- So when did you start
learning English then?
- I guess it started from high school.
We had English school
back in elementary school
and middle school but-
- People only drop it, I've noticed.
- They don't even care.
We don't know when to use English.
But then I got into WWE.
- Really?
- Back then it was cute, WWF.
- That's when you got into WWF.
- Oh my god.
- Let me explain.
I just used to, naturally watching
Japanese professional wrestling
because my dad was a physician
for that Japanese Wrestling Federation,
that organization.
So it was just natural for me
to watch professional wrestling.
- And then you got into it from that.
- They came to Japan.
- So they had a tour in Japan.
- That was actually the
second time they took a tour.
I couldn't make it in the first time.
I think the first time they still had Rock
like Dwayne Johnson.
- Oh my god, that's going way back.
That's going so far back.
- The number one influencer
in the world, by the way.
- I guarantee there's a group
of really young people
watching this who are like,
"The Rock, isn't he the actor?
(laughter)
- He wasn't back then.
- I've just imagined you
younger, just going around,
"Can you smell what The Rock is cooking?"
(laughter)
That's your first sentence.
- Oh my god.
I remember in high school
or in middle school
when people would just say
that and just immediately fart.
(laughter)
- Seriously, farting?
- They were like, "Can you
smell what The Rock is cooking?"
It was just a joke and
everyone started doing it.
And it was so fucking annoying.
- That's hilarious. (laughter)
- Joey's like, "Damn, I
gotta write that down."
- It's a new joke.
- So wait, so you got
into WWF, at the time.
- Yes.
On that stage, I saw Triple
H was actually the star,
the champion, at the time.
(talk over each other)
You need to understand how old I am.
I'm not gonna mention
that, but- (laughter)
Let's keep it a secret.
I wanna stay mysterious.
- Of course.
- So Triple H just came out.
I wasn't in the front row
but very close to front row
so I could just feel actually
his water splashing at me.
- Wow.
- So you were in the splash zone?
- Yeah.
- You could smell what he was cooking.
(laughter)
- Splashing what? Sweat.
- No, he does this, I don't
know if he's still doing it.
He just puts water in his mouth and -
- Yeah.
- When he comes out.
I remember as a kid, I used to try
and I begged my parents
to buy me the wrestling
action figure set.
And they were like, "No, Connor,
"that's got three zeros,
we're not." (laughter)
I was stumped.
- I never got into wrestling.
My uncle was a pretty big fan.
My Japanese uncle was a pretty big fan
of the Japanese wrestling side.
But I don't know, I never like really sat,
I know if I sit down and watch it though,
I think I'd love it.
- It seems like anime with
real people, you what I mean.
- Yeah, basically.
- The only thing I know about wrestling is
from Super Eyepatch Wolf
videos about wrestling.
That's pretty much my
knowledge on wrestling.
It seems like something
I could probably get
into if I had the time to commit to it,
'cause it seems like a lot of fun.
- Isn't it basically just a pantomime.
It's a stage performance.
It's like a theatrical thing.
- Exactly.
- Kind of like a Final
Fight with a drummer.
(laughter)
You enjoy Haggar doing a lot of that.
- Yeah, exactly.
'Cause it's all coordinated, right?
- Yeah, it's coordinated as far as I know.
And I think there are very famous moments
where they, because I
remember seeing in my
recommended top 10 ad-libs in wrestling
or something, I can't remember what.
- What was the ad-lib?
- I can't remember what it was.
It was like someone
meant to slam the table
but he slammed his face. (laughter)
And I was like, "Oh shit, what?"
- Coming up next on WatchMojo. (laughter)
- So did you ever think about,
I know this is gonna be a weird question.
But did you ever think about,
"I wanna be a wrestler."
Or did you ever think about
going into that side of things?
- Not really 'cause I just wanted to
get to know them more.
But that's it.
Maybe become a physician like my dad
or maybe a translator, I don't know.
- But it's basically like us with anime
where we saw anime and
we saw it's in Japanese.
So that was our motivation
to learn Japanese
for anyone who did at that age.
- But we didn't wanna go
into the anime industry.
We just wanted to talk about it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I don't have the physical
for wrestling, obviously.
I don't know if you guys can tell
but I'm very short
compared to these huge guys.
- I don't think I'm that tall.
- They are giants.
(laughter)
- I don't know how tall
my audience think I am
'cause everyone assumes I'm really short.
The first comment I always get is,
"Man, you're a lot taller
than I thought you'd be."
- I have the opposite thing.
In real life, people are like,
"I thought you were taller."
I'm like, "What? Fuck off."
- It might just be the white
man and Asian man stereotype.
It's like, "He's Asian
so he must be short.
"He's white so he must be tall."
- I remember when we aired
our Akiba video and everyone,
all the comments were,
"I can't believe Garnt's
taller than Connor."
My image is shattered.
- People for some reason
think I'm six foot 10.
I don't know why people think that.
I'm just a normal guy, leave me alone.
Stop bullying me.
- Wait, so you got into WWF.
- Yeah.
You don't really wanna
learn language from them.
- I think it'd be fantastic
if I met a Japanese person
who spoke like a WWF folk.
- Like you suck, I don't say that.
I try not to say.
- I just realized everything they say
is so anti-Japanese culture.
It's so in your face
and that's so opposite to everything.
- To be fair,
if a Japanese person
came up to me and said
do you smell what The Rock is cooking?
I'll be like, "Dude, you are awesome."
I love you right now.
- And then farts.
(laughter)
- You got me.
So I remember 'cause I
interviewed you for my channel.
- I think it was-
- Last year.
- Last year, right?
- At AX.
- Yeah, at AX.
We did an interview together
and I got to know a lot
about your backstory.
And we'll obviously get more
into that in this episode.
But
as you were saying at the beginning,
before you came into the JAV world
you went to journalism,
with the baseball stuff?
- Yes.
- So I wanna know now,
now that I know that you
were into WWF before that,
how did it go from WWF
to baseball journalism?
- I was in a company.
So I didn't have a choice.
My boss decide where I should go.
Baseball is what Japanese
people watch the most,
the Japanese people-
- So would you have liked to have done,
what, wrestling journalism?
- So that was your aim?
- Mm-hmm.
- That's pretty interesting.
- I'm kidding.
(laughter)
- But now you get to talk about
WWF (talk over each other)
- Did you get any say in doing baseball?
Do you like baseball?
- I had no idea.
I didn't know anything about the Ruth.
This dude is protecting this
space, I didn't understand.
I've never watched baseball.
I've been to girls'
school, girls only school
from elementary school for 12 years.
I was in
one gender.
- I'm the same.
- Joey went to an all boys' school.
- For six years?
- Yeah. For six years.
So middle school and
high school was all boys.
- So that was half.
'Cause elementary as well.
- Yeah.
- I didn't know they had a
girls only elementary schools.
Is that a thing in the UK?
- I don't know.
- You pay a lot, I think, for it.
- It's like private school
'cause you got to pay a premium,
I think, if you want your girls
to be in an all girls' school.
- Not surrounded by those dirty boys.
(laughter)
- Disgusting boys.
- Stay away from boys.
- You say that as you're with three boys.
So from my understanding, 'cause you were
in a girls' school your
entire time, right?
They still play baseball
though in girls schools
or I guess it's softball, right?
- Some, only a few.
So I had no idea how the sport functioned.
- 'Cause baseball is pretty
popular in Japan, isn't it?
- Yes, it is.
- Is it the most popular
sport or is that soccer?
- I should say baseball.
- Might be baseball.
- I've no idea.
- I think the top three
sports from what I remember
here is baseball, soccer and sumo.
I think those are top three most popular.
Obviously, they play other sports
like wrestling, for example.
I think baseball is
probably the most popular.
- They have the 143 games at least a year.
- Jesus.
- More than.
- 'Cause I know a lot of American teams
scout out Japanese baseball players.
- I don't wanna talk out my ass
'cause I literally know
nothing about baseball.
I've been to one baseball game in America
and basically, the only
way I could really have fun
was just to get belligerently drunk.
And that's the what everyone
else seemed to be doing.
- Isn't it really slow, baseball?
At least in America, they had an ad break
after every throw or something.
Maybe we're exaggerating.
That's what it feels like
watching sports in the US.
- I don't know.
It just feels like one of those
really boring sports to watch.
I'm gonna piss off a lot
of baseball fans now.
- Also, if you're pissing off people,
dude, American football
is so fucking boring.
And they actually do have an ad
every time anything happens.
It's so annoying.
- I can understand American football.
American football, when it's in motion,
it's one of the most
exciting sports to watch.
It just has too many breaks.
But sports like baseball, cricket,
golf.
I don't understand the
appeal of watching them.
- I really like the cricket.
(laughter)
I never watched baseball.
I never watched soccer.
I always used to watch the cricket.
And if you thought going to
a baseball game was slow,
go to a cricket game.
- Well, that's like a four day thing.
- Oh no, no, no, no, no.
You're talking about the test cricket,
which is one game is five days long.
There's three different
types, I can't believe
I'm gonna talk about cricket
in this podcast. (laughter)
- It's very educational.
- I have a good story about it.
- So basically, cricket has
three different types of games.
There's the test cricket,
which is the really long one
that most people associate
cricket with which is five days.
No one goes to watch those.
They do, but you have to be retired.
And have literally nothing else to do.
'Cause it's five days.
And then there's the, what they call,
the one day international
or the ODI, which is,
it only goes for one day.
- This man knows his shit, Jesus.
- I'm into cricket.
And then there's a shorter version
which is called the Twenty20
which usually only goes
for about three hours.
- Only three hours.
- It's speed running cricket.
And going to watch the Twenty20 cricket,
the short one is really exciting
because they have a
limited number of balls.
So they have no choice,
but to try and smack
the ball as many times as they want.
So it's way more interesting.
Whereas test cricket, they have five days
so they can take their time.
- And is it true that after the five days
you can still come out with no winner?
- Yeah, there's draws.
- There's draws.
- The best analogy I heard for that
is imagine having sex for four days,
and then in the end, nobody comes.
(laughter)
That's test cricket.
- That's what it feels like sometimes.
The test cricket, at least in Australia,
at least in my family, we
would put on the test cricket,
we put it on the TV and then
just have it in the background
and do other stuff around the house.
So every now and then we will
come into the living room
being like, "Who's winning?"
I wouldn't sit in front of the
TV for five days being like,
"Oh my God, this is so exciting."
Most of the time nothing's happening.
Edge of your seat stuff.
- When I was younger and my
whole family likes cricket
but I don't like it.
And I've made that very clear to them,
that I didn't like cricket.
So I'm 13 years old and it's Christmas.
Guess what the main gift they got me was?
- Cricket bat?
- A ticket to watch
The Ashes or something.
- The Ashes.
And I was like, "Mum,
I didn't ask for this.
"I asked for Yu-Gi-Oh cards."
(laughter)
"I know there's no center, mum.
"Come on, I'm not putting
up with this act anymore.
"This is bullshit."
And I'm pretty sure my
parents bought me it
just so that my dad could be like,
"Well, if you don't
want it, I'll take it."
I like how I'm just calling out my parents
especially on this podcast.
- But did you get Yu-Gi-Oh cards?
- No, I didn't.
I just had to forfeit my main gift
which is a ticket to The Ashes.
- If I were you I would have gone and sold
that ticket to a friend
and used that money
to buy Yu-Gi-Oh cards.
- I should have done that.
One of my 13 year old friends
was gonna go to The Ashes alone.
Like, "Go on, go to the middle
"of fucking nowhere in England."
- "And watch a game for five days."
So you eventually though had to get
a better understanding of baseball
because that was essentially your job?
- I had to get a scoreboard, a scorecard,
score book as well,
we call in Japanese kinda like
a baseball cap, the manager kind of thing.
- It seems like you were
very interested in it.
(laughter)
- You think. (laughter)
- So how long did you do that for?
- About a year as a baseball reporter.
I also did editing.
On that note, can I just...
- We completely forgot that we had gifts.
- Forget about my boring career.
- No.
We wanna hear about it.
- It's part of the lure.
(talk over each other)
- So this is summertime in Japan.
So I brought Ochugen
which is summer gift.
- It's got pikachu on it.
- Yes, pikachu and eevee on it.
- Cute.
- Where did you get that from?
- Pokemon Center.
- Pokemon Center, really?
I go to the Pokemon Center quite often
but I've never seen anything like this.
Let's open it up.
- They have collaboration with this.
Rusk.
- Ochugen.
There's plenty of words
'cause of Pikachu.
- Should we open it?
Can I open it up?
- Yeah, sure.
- So is this a traditional Japanese gift
where you give in the summertime then?
- Especially for business partners,
the people you wanna suck up to.
- I still don't understand the intricacies
of Japanese business etiquette
because there is an etiquette
behind Japanese businesses.
Do you wanna show off on camera?
- Yeah. It's a rusk, which is
a biscuit.
It's really nice.
- Let me see this.
- It's probably very famous in Japan.
It's from Gunma Prefecture.
- That looks good.
Well, we won't eat it
on this episode because
we don't want an ASMR
episode, but thank you.
Thank you.
- Also, Connor, happy birthday.
- I had no idea.
I had no idea.
- At the time of filming,
it was just Connor's
birthday last weekend.
- Happy birthday.
What'd you get, Connor?
What'd you get?
- It's a Pokemon sweet, it says.
Is it a cake of some sort? Pokemon cake.
I don't wanna take it all out and ruin it
but it's very cute.
I'll put that away for
now, but thank you so much.
- Man, you're much nicer
than our previous guest.
He just took all of our beer.
(laughter)
Thanks, Chris.
- We love you, Chris.
We love you.
- I'm gonna ask something
So I watched Joey's video
where he interviewed you
and I watched a ton of videos
that you were in on YouTube.
(laughter)
(talk over each other)
- Because earlier, I was
doing my research to Connor
about your career and he
just bust out laughing.
- I'm sorry, you know how it is.
- I know.
- I wanted to ask because
it must be, I don't know,
I just wanna know.
On Joey's video, all the
comments on every single video
that you're in are always the same.
It's like, "Opens up
Chrome tab to search."
Or it's like, "How did you like not
"look at your breasts or whatever."
Does that get annoying
when you just wanna collaborate
on a podcast like this?
- Of course and I feel sorry for Joey too.
(talk over each other)
I also invited him to join my radio show.
When we post and
we share, we retweet,
there is at least one comment, at least.
- Always.
- -one comment saying,
"Is Aki okay with this?
"Maybe they're gonna have a threesome."
What the...
- They just think that you
just cannot stop having sex.
- I'm like, "A, it was a job.
"not a lifestyle."
- Yeah, exactly.
- And B, I was fully retired
even at that time and I am now.
- But even if you were still working in it
the assumption that you just,
"I've gotta make a porno
"I've gotta fuck something and film it."
It's so strange.
- I feel bad for you.
I didn't really care
because it's just my comments, whatever.
'Cause the whole point
of my interview with you
was to get to know you as a person.
- Thank you.
- And obviously, of
course, it's inevitable
that we're gonna cross that path
because we're gonna
talk about your career.
Obviously, it wasn't every comment.
It was a lot of comments.
But I saw a lot of comments
as well, who were like,
"I totally saw a different light in her.
"She's actually really nice person.
That was my whole aim.
But of course, the internet is
always gonna be the internet.
I would be really annoyed if I was you.
If I went onto an interview
of some person or anybody-
- I just appreciate this, you guys so much
for bringing me out here
in spite of all those
future idiotic comments.
I can see that.
- We wanna to bring this up to call out
the fucking comments now.
- 'Cause what's gonna happen is
someone's gonna immediately
type this comment
before they watch the video.
They get 30 minutes in and they're like,
"Oh shit, I gotta delete that."
(talk over each other)
- And if you don't you're
just gonna be casted
as a clown in the comments section.
- At least be creative.
That's all I want.
- We don't need the same
five million incognito mode
comments that we're gonna
see you on every video.
- Be a man, don't use incognito.
Keep that shit in your history.
(talk over each other)
- Assert dominance.
'Cause the question I had was
you've had a very varied career
in terms of everything you do now.
When I was reading up,
you were a streamer, you're a cosplayer.
You were a writer.
You've done a lot of things
but has your career in the
Japanese adult video industry,
has that affected how people view you
when you're doing other things at all?
- I appreciate that people started
knowing me because of JAV.
I still keep the same name
because that's the name people know me.
I appreciate that
for that.
Because of that experience, I get to more
I get to speak more,
I get to have interesting conversation
because of that experience.
People just forever see me as JAV actress
even though I'm retired
but it just doesn't matter.
- 'Cause I think Mia Khalifa recently
she had, I think it was
a breakdown On Twitter
or Instagram, something similar.
- I remember reading up about it
where she actually regrets working in porn
because of how it just
completely dehumanized her
and affected her in a way
that she can never recover.
So I guess for you,
have you ever thought that you've
regretted that career at all?
- The reason right now I'm
not making an only fan account
or I'm not doing any nudity works is
(talk over each other) (laughter)
because I wanna redeem
myself, not as a JAV actress,
past or current, because I
wanna have a second career.
I wanna show people that
you don't really have
to keep taking off your clothes
just because you did it once.
That's why I'm encouraged to do this,
that's being myself.
- That's why I have so
much respect for you
because anybody else
would change their name
after JAV because they think that
if they see that name,
people are only gonna
remember me for that thing.
But the fact that you did
it just goes to show that
I can grow out of this.
I'm confident enough in myself
that I'll be able to
sell myself as a person
and not just the person
that once used to do porn.
That's really cool.
- That's big dick energy right there.
(laughter)
- I have to embrace my past.
I'm not ashamed of it.
I'm not necessarily proud of it.
I've never been proud of what I do
as newspaper reporter or as a teacher.
Some
actress say,
"We are helping Japan
to have a low crime rate, low
sex crime rate or something."
But maybe it's true.
But I guess if you're
doing any kind of a job,
you're helping somebody in a way.
You don't really have to be proud of it.
- Of course.
- You're working.
I'm not necessarily proud of it
but I am proud of it that I'm
kind of growing out of it.
It was a stepping stone for me.
I'm not doing the same thing
I do wear a sexy contrite
or maybe sexy cosplay, but
I'm not showing anything more.
I'm not making a secret
account to show more
so people can subscribe
and maybe pay more.
I don't do that.
(laughter)
- I'm just very curious
about how you transitioned
from being a baseball journalist
to working in the JAV industry.
That's quite a career change.
- That's a bit of a job.
(talk over each other)
- That's a standard promotion
as far as I remember.
- I changed from working at
the BBC to doing YouTube.
I thought that was a big career shift
but that's nothing
compared to you, I think.
- I've always loved writing.
I still do.
Actually, my physical book is coming out.
- You memoir?
- Not necessarily memoir, it's
about, I think as a reporter
a report of JAV industry,
not everything about me.
It's not necessarily expose
but you can read and actually know
and how much I made
during those years too.
I'm gonna put out all of that.
It's a legal paper, tax paper.
It's a definite season.
Nobody can expose that much.
But it's about me so I guess it's okay.
- That was a flawless
transition to an ad, by the way.
(laughter)
- And what's happening behind the mosaic.
- That sounds like a Netflix documentary,
behind the mosaic.
- That's such a good title.
- That would be a good title for the book,
behind the mosaic.
- I think I watched Joey's video
yesterday before we did this.
- I think he asked something similar
but I think we really wanna know
did you know someone
that was in the industry?
Was it a Craigslist ad that you were like,
"Porn actress needed."
How did you find your way into that?
- Actually, I try to have
her interesting part-time job
because I was
became teacher from a reporter.
I got more free time.
I have a decent schedule.
As a reporter, it's 24/7 almost like.
But as a teacher, you have
classes and that's it.
I'm gonna have an
interesting part time job.
- You were that teacher.
You were that teacher with that show.
- I didn't mean to do anything explicit.
- Were you doing both at
the same time at any point?
- No, not really.
- Not really? (talk over each other)
- We had a photo shoot.
Once the DVD came out,
I should just leave
before parents find out.
I wasn't teaching any young kids.
- So you started out
doing photo shoots first?
- It was a gradual because
if it comes out soon
then maybe your friends
gonna find out soon and
maybe you wanna quit.
- So how did you even get the
offer to do the photo shoot?
- So I was just looking for
interesting part-time job.
My friend actually told me who was working
at this PR company, a gaming PR company.
And she said, "I have this part-time job
"where I just jump in."
It's nothing sexual.
Don't expect too much.
- Just when your friend
says I have this job.
- Side job.
(laughter)
They go to a mixer.
We say (in foreign language) in Japanese.
Mixer, boys and girls.
And sometimes they don't have
enough girls so I fill in.
And I just pretend I'm one of them.
She doesn't know anyone at the party
but she just pretends she's
one of them, a friend of them.
- So to explain what a mixer is, it's
like a group dating
session but not really.
- It's like groups speed dating.
- Wow, weird,
- It's really strange.
Usually, it's three guys, three girls.
- Or even numbers.
- I have heard of this actually.
- Or an even number.
The girls just chat up all the
boys, see which one's good.
The boys chat up all the
girls see which one's good.
- I'm too competitive.
(laughter)
- And then they're like,
"I'm gonna take her.
"I'm gonna take him.
I'm gonna take her kind of thing.
It's really weird.
I've never done it.
- I don't know.
I've never done it either.
That sounds like a lot of pressure.
- That sounds like you would do.
- No, I couldn't do that
because I think I'd be like,
"What do you mean all
three didn't pick me?"
I'm joking, by the way.
- It's kinda like I'm gonna
introduce you to my friends.
But in plural not just singular.
- I'm gonna sound like Dennis
from Sunny in Philadelphia
- In everyone else's mind
it's just a social gathering.
To you is like, "How do I gamify this?
"How do I win?
"You've lost.
"I need to win this."
It's like, "Choke on it,
"we're just trying to chat a few girls.
- I turn everything into the Olympics.
I'm that guy who's like, "It's
a competition? Oh, okay."
- Game on.
- Yeah.
- So you did that job.
- No, my friend did that job.
I thought that's interesting,
pretending to be someone else.
So I'm gonna do something
more interesting.
- Did you do on purpose
to one-up your friend?
- You're turning it into a competition.
- I always want something to write about.
To have that out of my experience,
not trying to, I don't know,
sneaking to somebody through,
or try to get information out of somebody,
but more like, I wanna talk about myself.
So that I don't really
have to hurt anyone.
There was a part time
job called, trying out...
In Japanese, it was called
adult goods monitor.
- Adult goods monitor.
- I don't know if you guys
use the same name, monitor.
It's just testing adult goods.
We call that monitor in Japanese.
- So you were like a game
tester but for adult toys.
- I applied for that job
but then those company who they say that,
we're looking for girls, for people,
for adult goods monitor, those companies
are always JAV management companies.
So they just try to lure them in.
- That was like the fishing hook.
- If you're interested in that,
then maybe if you get
more money doing that.
- And then you were like, "Sounds good."
- I don't think I would get hired.
I wasn't that young.
Many JAV actress sell
themselves as 18 or 19,
but they're actually not underage, 20.
But they sell themselves as
younger, of course..
So I was like, maybe it
could be interesting.
I should just see how
many offers I'm gonna get.
- Get that ego boost, I see.
- Then I got offers, decent offers.
Then it was just,
it couldn't get out of your mind.
- And then it just opened the flood gates.
Then you were in.
- It's like a Raid Shadow
Legends sponsorship.
They throw too much money at you, man.
- Lately, things are more legal and okay.
Back then, it was more sketchy definitely.
- That's really interesting.
I didn't realize that they
hire people like that.
- 'Cause I've always wondered how,
even in the US as well, how do they do it?
I'm sure in the US it's
probably a Craigslist ad.
But I guess in Japan,
it's not really like that.
I don't imagine flipping through
a part-time job magazine
and being like, "Oh, okay."
- I don't think it's a Craigslist ad.
I think you
could have done a ton of tests done
before you can even do anything.
So I think, there's a lot of that.
- There's always another way.
But I wrote that,
everything in my book which I hope
it's gonna come out in English.
- I don't really have to keep it a secret.
There are people called
scout man, it's scouting.
So if you know, at least one scout
and he's gonna lead you
to one management company.
It's like agencies but we never
work individually in Japan
I guess in the State, they're
more like free agents.
- Is it like
how an idol agency works then?
Because I saw that you were
in a JAV idol group as well.
What was that about?
- I hated that.
(laughter)
I hated that.
- Spill that tea.
- I never asked for that.
- Gotta get some tea so
you can spill it out.
- So your agency was like,
"You're in an idol group now."
- More like, you're happier.
You're doing something beside porn.
So you're happy.
I hated that attitude too.
- You should be grateful
that we put you in something you hate.
- But I never asked it.
I'm not an idol fan.
- What was that like?
'Cause I don't know anything about it.
So what was that about?
What did you have to do exactly?
- I just sing a cover song.
It wasn't even an original song.
- How many of you were there?
- At some point it became more than 15.
And it got just too many.
- Oh my God.
- I was imagining three or four.
- Idol groups here are more.
We need more.
- Because at the time, AKB48 was huge.
So they got more and more.
- They're like, "Wait, so if we get 49,
"it's unstoppable."
(talk over each other)
- I'm sure they wanted to make it to 69.
(laughter)
But just too many.
- I'd join an idol group
if it's part of the 69.
That sounds fun.
- That would be such an
amazing conversation starter.
- It's like, "Dude, my favorite
idol group 69. (whispers)"
(laughter)
- Maybe TKY69, like Tokyo
or (in foreign language) .
- The 69%. (laughter)
- So wait, how long did
you have to do that for?
- Only for couple months, I guess
because I started being busy.
I became a freelance as an actress.
Sometimes, some actresses,
of course like in the US,
you are contracted to do only with
what was the name of
the company? I forgot.
- Brazzers.
- Brazzers
- That was actually it?
(laughter)
- Sometime like you're contracted
but I got free from the contracts.
So I could just shoot as many as I want.
- Because I remember in the
interview, I think I asked,
at the peak of your career,
how often were you doing it?
- And I think you said you
were doing a shoot every
two days or something.
- That was exhausting,
sometime three days in a row.
- I think it was like
15 shifts in a month.
- More than 15.
- Something like that.
- That was exhausting.
- Is it even fun at all at that point?
Or you're like, "Fuck, fine."
- It started becoming fun
when it became a routine.
I've done all the different situations.
I was a MILF at some point.
(talk over each other)
And a TR, I've done that already.
Something like time stopping thing.
(talk over each other)
- I will never understand time stop play.
I don't know why they-
- It's like, why do you want
to suddenly slowly become Dio?
(laughter)
How do you watch JoJo and like,
"I wanna jerk off to this right now."
- It's like a Dio doujinshi.
If Dio was a hella horny.
And he's like, (talk over each other)
- Have you seen fan art where
they draw Dio and Jonathan
as the 15th chapel artwork,
the way he's like God light.
- Yeah.
- It's like, yes.
What I wanna know is how,
'cause if someone was like,
"Connor, do you wanna do porn?"
And I was like, "Yeah, sure."
How do you adjust your
mindset to being like,
"I gotta do this."
Or were you like, "Oh yeah sure."
And you just did it.
- In the beginning, I was just curious.
My curiosity was overflowing.
"Let's do it, I'm so excited."
But in the beginning,
I have to play a role
of very modest, very shy.
- Like the innocent girl?
- Yeah.
- I've only had sex with a guy
a couple of times kind of thing.
That wasn't me in person, by the way.
So I couldn't say anything.
I could just mutter. (laughter)
- Just be that Coudray girl.
- I shouldn't say any vulgar words.
I don't know how to respond.
Can I just say it's good?
I shouldn't want more but
I should just reciprocate.
- You just have to act
like the inexperienced one.
- That's always a thing.
- I've noticed that if there
are any new JAV actresses
that come onto the scene,
that's almost always
the first one that they do.
And I think you were saying as well
the first couple of ones
are the highest paying,
for some reason.
I don't know why.
You'd think that the more you
do, the more you get paid.
But it's the opposite in the JAV industry.
- It's the opposite.
- Unless you start doing
something more like the back door.
(laughter)
- So every time you do something new,
it's paid more.
- Yeah, you're paid more.
- First time is always
the best time for them.
- I have a question.
You said you were in different scenarios
and acted different characters.
Do you have a script or do
you have to ad lib everything?
- Sometimes, we have a script but rarely.
We have to ad-lib.
- It must be so annoying having a script.
You're like, "I just wanna do it.
"I don't wanna do this.
Let me just say shit.
I know what I'm doing.
- And especially for sex scene,
they don't have a script at all.
Maybe in a script is a
position and that's it.
- Hey, fellatio, 69-
- Time stop.
- Do not go longer than
three minutes, 30 on doggy
or we're canceling the shoot.
- Yeah. Like 45 minutes in total.
- Do you have to remember that?
Or does the other actor
have to remember that?
- In the beginning because
I was just reciprocating.
I didn't have to do anything.
My director didn't want
me to read the script
'cause that could be too much acting.
- I would have just loved if you would
in the position, then
busted out the script.
- What's my line again?
- What's my line, chemo, cheese?
All right, I got it.
- But if you become
what they call veteran,
experienced,
then you have to be a cougar
or you have to be the aggressive one.
- So your role changed over time
the more you're in the industry.
- I have to actually learn how
to say vulgar word, vulgar language.
I actually took a note,
how to speak dirty.
- The vulgar word notebook.
- I wrote every single onomatopoeia
I could come up with to describe.
I read a lot of Ecchi Manga.
- You actually used Manga
as your source material.
- Manga is god.
- Isn't that so ironic.
There's seriously a loop going on
because I guarantee
that Ecchi Manga actors
learn how to say those things from JAV.
And JAV actresses use that.
It's a cycle.
- It's a recycle.
It's a good recycle.
- That's so funny.
- It's going green.
- Whereas in English porn
if you're just Australian,
you're like, "That's
it. That's the script.
"Just keep calling him like you would."
- What's your nationality?
Okay. Just use that.
- Just keep talking to him
like he's a close friend.
(laughter)
- I watched this US porn.
There was, what was that?
Avengers.
It was about Avengers.
But in Japanese, it was called hamangers.
(laughter)
I don't know the US title.
If this was a porn or something.
But the look was amazing.
They were all dressed in, Hulk was Hulk.
- There's so many horrifying ones.
Have you seen the SpongeBob one?
There's a SpongeBob porno.
It's horrifying.
I'll show you later.
It looks disgusting.
- There's also the Pokemon one as well.
- Strokemon,
(laughter)
- And they have a Squirtle?
- No, it's Pikachu.
- Squirtle.
- I'm just curious.
- It should have been Squirtle.
But no, it was Pikachu
but like the girl was Pikachu.
- It's horrible.
They put this woman in
full yellow body paint
and it's disgusting.
Honestly, it's horrible.
- There's Misty.
So it's perfect, that's the actress.
And like maybe Ash and Brock do-
- No, she's called Fisty.
- Fisty. (laughter)
I think they changed Brock-
- To Cock.
- And Ash is Gash.
You think it's Misty.
And it's a perfect scenario.
And I don't know, maybe
Pikachu watch from the side.
No, they made the girl Pikachu.
So it's Brock.
I'm sorry, Cock and Ash-
- We are not getting ads on the episode.
- Hey, follow us on Patreon.
And they're doing it with Pikachu.
And I'm like, "Why?"
It would have been fine if
you just did it with Misty.
Why do you have to do it with a Pokemon.
- Who's ever seen a Pikachu
and gone, I wanna fuck that?
- There's a lot on the internet.
- You clearly haven't
seen the furry community.
- Exactly.
As a professional, as a true professional
what is your opinion on the Western
porn industry compared to Japan?
- When I watched the hamangers.
- I don't know if that's
indicative of all porn.
- I was just shocked at how
much they didn't do script-wise.
They had a drama scene and that's it.
Like for sex, they didn't do anything.
They didn't say anything
related to the story.
- I don't think Westerners care.
- It was just, "That's it.
"I'm gonna come."
(laughter)
It just had nothing.
It was like people at Halloween.
- They're not even acting.
This isn't professionalism.
- To be fair, when you've seen the way
they act in some of these pornos,
you're like, "No, I really
don't want you to act.
"I really don't."
- Some of these actors are not actors.
- The bathtub one,
that's the one.
There's a shark in the bathtub.
Have you not seeing that one?
(instrumental music) (blows whistle)
- Get out of the water, there's a shark.
- What, a shark?
- Get out of the water.
There's a shark in the water.
- No, wait a minute, there's
no shark in the bathtub.
- Aren't you glad you had a
life guard here to save you?
- Have you seen that?
- I've seen that one.
(laughter)
- A shark in the bathtub,
the Spielberg- (laughter)
- The Jaws Parody.
There's a guy in the bathtub
and a woman comes in
actually looking very sexy.
And like, "There's a
shark in your bathtub."
And he's like, "No,
there isn't." (laughter)
It's really dumb.
It's very dumb.
Everyone who's seen it is
like, "Oh yeah, it's cursed."
I'm sure you two have.
- There's so many memes of bad porn acting
that it's just become a joke.
There's YouTube channels
that are dedicated
to just uploading badly acted porn.
- But the Pikachu one, does the actress
say pika Pikachu?
- Yeah, it's really disgusting
- The entire time that
Pikachu is getting boned,
all she says is pika, pika.
- I cannot see the Pikachu
surprise face meme anymore.
That's gonna look like
old face (laughter).
- Pikachu's surprise face,
"That's what my butt
hole looks like, what?"
(laughter)
It's pretty gross.
- It's so gross because
she's full body paint
but then they spread
and it's like, "Oh no."
(laughter)
Oh no. Oh no.
- It's pretty nasty.
- Courtesy of Aki for showing me that.
- Aki finds all the weird porn.
She showed me that one.
She also showed me, there
was a Spiderman one.
It was really bad.
There was also a Barack
Obama one, I remember.
- Do they do porn parodies in Japan?
- We cannot do that.
Sometimes we try to do it
but sometimes we have to take it back.
There are some parodies.
- Because of the fair use thing.
'Cause fair use is not a thing,
so much so that not even porn can parody.
- I've seen a little cosplay porn.
Does that count as parody?
- Sometimes
the publishing company
say no, we don't do that.
Then they have to take back sometimes.
They were okay with Faye because Faye's-
- That makes sense why all the cosplays
I've seen is just Faye 'cause Faye's like,
"We want the porn."
This is how this helps
people get into our game.
- How it got started.
- That's why there's so
much Type-Moon doujinshi
as well because Type-Moon's like,
"Yes, give us all the porn."
- We wanna see another
Saber getting fucked
so we can sell more Sabers.
- Saber having sex with Saber,
the class or the character, we don't know.
Sorry, not a funny joke.
- Did you ever do any
of that kind of stuff?
Did you ever do cosplay stuff?
- No, only cosplay.
I never around to do the parody.
For parody, if your actress name
is too strong or too well-known
and that can just, I dunno,
that can be a nuisance in a way.
People are just distracted.
- They don't see the character,
they see the actress.
- That makes sense.
How did you then decide
to go, after you retired,
how did you decide to then go
from that to cosplay stuff?
- I actually loved cosplaying
because I looked totally different.
I think my first decent
cosplay was Danua from...
- From where?
- From what was that? Let me think.
Which one was that?
- What was the character name?
- Danua.
- Danua?
- Joey doesn't know something.
- I don't know either.
- Something fancy. I forgot-
- Describe the anime.
What's the anime about?
- It's a game.
- Granblue Fantasy.
- Oh, okay.
- There are just so many
characters, I forgot
what is Fate or I can't-
- It's one of those culture games.
- Which game was that?
Danua
with horns.
At that time, because I
have to shoot so many times
in a month, that I didn't have time
to catch up on any anime.
So maybe just one, I've
been always following
Detective Conan, Case Closed.
- I know you're a massive
fan of Detective Conan.
Every time I see your Instagram stories
there's usually something to
do with Detective Conan cops.
How many times have you
been to the Conan Cafe?
- I try to go there for
the third time this year
and then Corona virus hit.
I got a refund too.
- That's good.
- So what was the breaking
point where you decided,
I really wanna get out
of this industry now.
I wanna retire.
- Because it became a routine.
I want something new in my life.
I wanna feel new everyday.
- You just got bored of it.
- And I also wanna change
my look every single day.
You know what, cosplay's great.
I love manga and anime
forever.
I'm seeing maybe in the
future more and more,
I wanna to try different cosplay.
I don't wanna do them too much.
(laughter)
I didn't really want when
they started like taking off with cosplay,
just let me keep the cosplay,
Don't put it off, ruin it.
- You do see some cosplays on Twitter,
that it's this cosplay and
it's two pieces of material.
- Or it's not even that.
Sometimes it's like, "I'm cosplaying 02
from Darling in the Franxx
and it's just the wig.
And then nothing else.
I'm like great cosplay.
- That's on point for the
cosplay 'cause she is naked
from the first episode.
That's literally how her
character gets introduced.
- That was my bad.
- Because I remember in
the interview that we did
when I was talking about
like the cosplay stuff,
I remember you said something really funny
which is like your favorite
characters in any show
is usually the characters
that have really small breasts
and that you just feel sad
because you can't cosplay them.
- I always go for flats.
- I think you were saying you
cosplayed Ram from Re:Zero.
Your favorite character was-
- Beako.
- From Beatrice, right?
- Yeah, Beatrice.
- Another Beatrice done, yes.
(talk over each other)
- High five.
- I can't believe I'm
surrounded by three people.
How did we find the three people on earth?
The only three people who like Beatrice?
(talk over each other)
- He's a normie.
He's like, "I like Rem."
- I'm Rem or die, man, no in-between.
I loved wearing my Rem cosplay as well.
I love wearing female cosplays.
I feel like I have people
figured that out by now.
I don't know why it's so freeing,
especially skirts.
Skirts, you get so much movement.
You know what I mean?
Not that I wanna ever wear this-
- Maximum efficiency.
- When I'm filming a video
and I'm clowning around.
I'm like, "Oh wait, hold up,
you can actually fully stretch."
Jeans are too constricting.
- I feel the breeze on my balls.
- Yeah. (laughter)
- So liberating.
- I think the reason I
ever interacted with you
is 'cause you posted your Hestia cosplay.
- And you posted back. (laughter)
- Your posted yours. (laughter)
- Go, go, go.
- With the fucking gone
before his head gets out.
- That was mad JoJo vibes in that photo.
- I'd love to get you on one of the videos
to judge my cosplay sometime.
You're good.
- You're getting a professional cosplayer
to judge your videos for you.
- You can tell me how bad I am.
They just clown on me for 20 minutes.
- I've I've been on that show.
I've been on his series twice now.
Man, I've never had to
bleach my eyes faster.
- Didn't you get hives
or Aki got hives from one of the cosplays?
- One the wigs you bought,
I guess was really dirty
'cause he bought it
from a Chinese website.
- I buy the cheapest stuff I can find.
- What's hives?
- It's a skin rash.
- In the UK, it's called
something else, I think.
- I put it on in the video
just because I thought it was funny.
And then the next day I
just had hives on my neck.
And I'm like, "Connor-"
- You stayed till the next day?
- I was like, "Oh God, what's this?"
And then I thought about it.
I'm like, "How did I get this?
"Is this bed bugs or something?"
And then I thought back.
I'm like, "It's that fucking wig."
- It's so disgusting.
Do you make your own
or do you get them commissioned?
- I don't make on my own
but I ask someone to make one for me.
Or sometimes I just order
on Amazon if it's good MO.
There're a lot of knockoff on Amazon.
- Even on Amazon, they're all, I think,
re-routed through China because.
'Cause it's like Amazon Japan
and then it's three to four weeks.
- It sounds a bit suspicious
- A lot of them are just awful
'cause I remember my arm was red.
And I was like, "That is weird.
"That was strange."
- I was like, "Please throw it away."
- I normally throw most of them away.
- If it's just a small prop
and I just buy it on Amazon
because it's a fast delivery.
- So do you keep all your costumes.
- Sometimes I sell or I
just give away at at cons
because I go to anime
cons in the United States.
And I don't wanna carry all
the cosplays back to Japan.
- That makes sense.
- I'm curious.
Do you have any convention horror stories?
Because we have.
(talk over each other)
- We have a lot.
Has no one ever tried step the boundary,
ever do anything creepy
to you at a convention?
- Only at adult con,
which I don't go anymore.
- This actually I wanted to talk about.
Because when I was on
YouTube searching clips,
there are a lot from adult cons
and people seem overly
touchy at adult cons.
- They think it's okay.
- And then people just
they go up to you and immediately
put their arm around you.
I hate it when people do that to me.
I'm like, "What are you doing?
"I don't know you."
- It's like, "Please don't touch me."
- It was just odd seeing that.
And then people were like,
"Make out with each other."
- Wow.
- Is the adult con basically
as bad as it looks?
- First of all, in Japan, all those events
you can't even touch an idol
or a talent, maybe a handshake.
That's why we have handshake in event.
You get the handshake,
you get to feel her.
But hand is the only
area you get to feel her.
- I'm never washing this
hand ever again. (laughter)
- We are not Westerners.
So you are not even supposed
to put a hand on her shoulder
or not even on her hip.
I guess in the West, I'm okay.
We're taking photos together,
some people are very
gentle when I try to do air hand.
(laughter)
- It's called shoulder hand.
- I was internally dying
watching some of these clips.
People would just go up to you
and to start touching on you.
If someone did that to
me, I'd be like, "Ah."
- I'd be like, "This
mans' catching some hands"
Just smack him.
- It's weird that for some reason
just because it's an adult convention
that they can just do what they want.
- They try to grab you on
the chest area or back area.
- Really?
- Yeah. I know.
- What the fuck?
Did they ever get into trouble with that
or anything like that?
Do you have to act like nothing happened?
- Sometimes I just tell someone like,
"That guy just touched me."
And some people ask nicely, like,
"Is it okay I touch your breasts?"
(laughter)
Nice that you asked, but no.
But then they just try to be persistent.
Some people are persistent.
- The problem is they've calculated
that it's a bit rude to just do it
but they haven't quite
done the rest of it.
They're like, "I probably should ask."
(talk over each other)
- Excuse me, my lady, would
it be okay if I pertain-
- That's the same logic
of a child being like,
"If I say please, then
maybe I can get the cookie."
- So some people are persistent
and they won't take no for an answer.
- But they offer tips.
How much do I need to pay as a tip?
(talk over each other)
Some actresses in the
West, they take tips.
- Do they?
- Yeah.
- But I was like I don't
have a culture of tipping.
- This episode of Trash Taste
is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
ExpressVPN lets you access the internet
as if you're from a different country.
Like Joey is in a different Shirt.
- Oh my God, and we're in a different
position on the table.
- Ow, I hit my head.
(laughter)
- [Announcer] Netflix has
different shows and movies
available depending on where you are.
With ExpressVPN, you can
unlock thousands of new shows
and movies from streaming
libraries around the globe.
- Such as Star Trek's
discovery on Netflix UK
or Brooklyn Nine-Nine on Netflix Canada
or even Black Adam on Netflix UK.
I like that show.
- I actually really do like that show.
(talk over each other)
- There might be hundreds
of VPNs out there
but let me tell you
ExpressVPN, it hits different.
(laughter)
It's so fast that you
can stream everything
in hasty quality and not notice
any kind of buffering or lag.
- ExpressVPN the fastest fuck boy.
And not only that ExpressVPN is available
on every single device; phone, tablet,
PC, smart TV, you name it.
- ExpressVPN works with
many streaming services
such as Netflix, Amazon
Prime, BBC iPlayer,
YouTube.com and Hentai Haven.
(laughter)
- Before it got shut down.
- I genuinely actually have to use a VPN
to watch Hentai, I not joking.
- Not only that, but you can choose
from almost 100 different countries,
that's a lot of countries, (laughter)
- Why was that funny?
- It's so simple to use, just
fire up the ExpressVPN app
change your location, hit
connect, and then refresh the page
and show or movie you want to
watch will magically appear.
- He's fucking pantomiming with his hand.
- It's very distracting.
I'm trying to line read this
shit and he's going fucking-
- I think we all use ExpressVPN,
especially when watching anime.
Sites like Crunchyroll,
kinda blocked in Japan.
So the best way is to
just put on ExpressVPN,
you get past that immediately.
- And if you use our link today
that's expressvpn.com/TrashTaste,
you can get an extra three free months
of ExpressVPN for free.
That's expressvpn.com/TrashTaste.
Link's down in the description below.
- And now back to the video, baby.
- So obviously now that we've asked
about adult cons and normal conventions,
how is it from Japanese conventions
like Comiket to America ones?
- I get sometimes scared
just watching some cosplayer
getting overwhelmed by
those, the camera guys.
And they all take a low angle.
Sometimes they are too close.
I feel like they're just
taking photos of pores,
just pores on their skin.
- I've seen some videos.
And then it just seems like locusts.
They gather around and then-
- Japanese conventions by the way.
- And then they have no respect
for personal boundary lot of the times,
especially if someone's cosplaying.
- I think I saw a video of a cosplayer,
I think last Comiket that
was crying, breaking down.
- It was the Chinese Comiket.
- She wasn't used to it.
- And it's like, "She's crying
what is wrong with you?"
- Every now and then I see
in US conventions as well
some camera guys use the I'm a camera man
excuse to get close.
But nowhere near the Japanese ones.
- It's definitely a mob mentality.
They all come together.
- Everyone's doing it so
they get away with it.
- It's like if one cockroach is like,
"Okay guys, it's safe."
And then everybody- (laughter)
All right, let's go in for the kill.
- I never been to Japanese
Comike or any event in cosplay
because you're not allowed
to cosplay outside in Japan.
- I heard this.
- You actually need to
change at the event.
There's some kind of changing
area, that's just so much.
- Do you know why?
- They got some complaint
from neighbor areas.
- It's like, "I was just
taking my dog for a walk
"and this woman dressed
up in Ram just rocked up.
"And I don't like that character."
- That's crazy, how people
would complain about that.
- It's not good for the
scenery or something like that.
- You go to LA during AX.
And it's literally just
within a one kilometer radius.
- There was a really funny video last AX
of you know how in LA they
started implementing the scooters
that are (talk over each other)
The ones that you can just pick
up and go and then drop off.
It was a video of a guy
just full on Saitama
from one block to another (laughter)
just cruising down the road in a scooter.
He was going so fast.
It was just really funny
because everybody was
like, "Did you see that?"
- I love that about
AX.
They're just conventions,
just seeing random
cosplayers out and about.
- Walking into a Chick-fil-A
and seeing 80% of people in cosplay
is some of the funniest
things I've ever seen.
- There's obviously a lot of problems
with American conventions.
But I do think they are my favorite ones,
'cause it's such a fun atmosphere
and most people understand
that it's like, "We're
having a good time."
- Don't make things weird
- Don't make things weird.
If you see each other in a
Denny's, right nice, I see.
- I think especially recently,
people have definitely gotten more
whereabout checking each other
and making sure that I'm
not acting like an asshole
and everything like that.
Because I remember before
about five, 10 years ago,
conventions just seemed to be
operating on this other level.
(talk over each other)
It was a lot smaller, it's like orgies.
(laughter)
- It was an organized orgy essentially.
It's like, "Everybody who is cosplaying
"in Inuyasha stuff, meet
at the 10:00 PM orgy
"at the Inuyasha orgy in this hotel room."
- That's basically all
furry cons right now.
Well organized with a better mass orgy.
- Is that why I see a lot
of cosplay isn't consent.
- People will talk shit
and I know that there is,
what was that thing a while
back where people would
kiss in an anime, they would always run
up to each other and jump?
- Glomping.
I never went to conventions
during the glomp phase
but I saw videos of it, I'm like-
- They were full on
running into each other.
- This is like, man, I
like my personal boundaries
a lot of the times.
I like my personal space.
- And I think with the
general culture shift
to being a lot more
respectful as it should be.
I think that's just kind of pushed it all.
- 'Cause I think the
big difference I heard
about Japanese conventions
'cause I haven't been to Comiket yet,
but I've heard that people just go
to Comiket literally to shop.
You don't go for any events,
you don't go for the convention itself
essentially you buy what you
need and then you fuck off.
- It's basically getting heads
first on the latest doujinshi
from your favorite character,
artist or whatever.
And I'm like, I respect that.
I want first dibs on it.
- And you need to prepare a lot of coins
because they only take cash.
- I've never been either.
I don't want to go to summer Comiket.
- That sounds like hell.
- I've always wanted to
go to winter Comiket,
but the problem is I'm never in Japan
when winter Comiket is on
because I usually go to the US,
then go back to Australia to
go see my family for Christmas.
But I think winter Comiket
seems a lot more fun.
Summer just seems, summer
here just outside.,
it's just unbearable.
- in Japan, in general.
It's just too heated.
- Do you ever get used to it?
- It comes back every single year.
I say, "It's Japan.
"We live here, we've
gotta get used to it."
- I'm just dying right now.
I'm so pale.
I was not made for
anything above 20 Celsius.
Anything above 20, and I'm like (pants).
(laughter)
AC.
I can't handle this.
This is horrible.
I wanted to leave, but
obviously we can't leave.
- I can handle the heat because
Australia gets really
freaking hot in the summer.
But where I'm from, there's zero humidity.
And so it's not the heat that
kills me, it's the humidity.
It's the fact that you walk outside
and it feels like you're standing
in front of the heater the entire time.
- You feel disgusted by yourself.
- It's like, " I'm all
sticky and everything's ew."
- It's like a Metal Solid game,
I just gotta plan every
one of my movements
to make sure I'm always in
cover, I'm getting to shade.
Where's my box?
- Me and Connor have the complete opposite
taste when it comes to weather.
I love sunshine.
I love heat.
I remember Connor told me
that his favorite weather
like passing is just cloudy and cold.
And I'm like, "Man, that
sounds so dreary to me.
"That makes me so depressed."
'Cause when I wake up
and I see a cloudy day,
I just imagine waking up with a smile
and it just makes me feel worse.
- You know those days where all you
wanted to do was play video games?
When you wake up and you were
gonna play video games all day
and it's raining outside,
you're like, "Yes."
- I understand that.
'Cause you're like,
"No one's gonna ask me, it's
a nice day, go outside."
"No, I'm laying video games, mother."
- I just need sunshine.
Sometimes when it's sunny,
I just message Connor being like,
"Ain't it a beautiful day, Connor?
"Ain't it a beautiful fucking day today?"
- Just to annoy him.
- I'm there sweating at my desk
like, "I hate this.
"I hate this so much."
'Cause in the UK, we don't have AC.
It's not a thing 'cause normally,
it never used to get hot
enough where you would need it.
There's only one or two days a year.
- Even at the one year that
we went to go visit you guys
it was the heat wave that lasted a month.
- It's been like that a lot recently.
So you've got these houses
that are designed to keep in heat, no AC,
It's normally hotter inside
your house, 35 degrees.
It's hell, I hate it so much.
I was like in tears every day.
Like, "I just can't do it.
I can't be here anymore."
- How is the weather in Thailand?
- It's similar to what we have now.
So it's very hot, very humid.
- For all year round?
- All year round.
But our homes are designed for it.
We have very thin walls and everything.
So it's designed to get as
much heat out as possible.
And there's AC everywhere you go as well.
- It's unfair, you max
the Thai skill tree.
I went down just the
British, I don't even know
what you get in the British skill tree,
just poor taste in food.
(laughter)
Unfair.
- This is just out of nowhere question
but how is milk in each country.
I've been told by my
friend in California that,
we were just talking about Baskin-Robbins
because we have always,
each year they have Pokemon
collaboration at Baskin-Robbins.
He was complaining that milk here
or ice cream here is too heavy
because of the milk,
because we use whole milk.
In California, they prefer low fat or-
- Grass-fed milk.
(laughter)
- Organic.
- Organic grass-fed milk.
- I didn't notice that
because I realized now when
you told me that the other day,
I was like, "Wait, there's
never any semi skimmed
"or no fat milk option here."
You can order at Starbucks, but-
- You can buy low-fat
milk at supermarkets.
- Can you? I never see it.
- The supermarket near
my house has skim milk,
low fat milk, high calcium
milk, stuff like that.
- I always wondered, I was like,
"Why does milk tastes so
rich when I came here?"
I'm like, "This is weird."
- It's that 100% cream stuff.
- I always get the half
back 'cause I'm like-
- I like the thick stuff
because in Australia-
(laughter)
- He likes the thick stuff, Luke.
- I like my dummy thicc milk.
I like my dummy thicc milk
because in Australia as well
we didn't really have a
whole, it's like Japan,
we don't really have a
whole variety of milk.
Obviously, we have the full cream stuff
and the low fat stuff
but it's not like America where it's like
"Would you like 1%, 2%, 5%, 10%?"
It's like, "Just give me
milk. I just want milk."
- I haven't noticed much
of a difference 'cause
I don't normally, I don't know.
I only have milk with my coffee.
And I don't eat ice
cream too often either.
- I'm not a fan of soft serve.
And that seems to be
the most popular thing.
- I really like soft serve.
- It's too milky.
If I want milk, I'll just drink milk.
I want ice cream not ice
cream that tastes like milk.
- Well, then just don't get
the vanilla flavor stuff,
get the weirder soft serve.
- True. Like matcha soft
serve is pretty good,
but just no more vanilla.
- Matcha, black sesame is really good.
- But vanilla is my favorite
flavor of ice cream.
- Well, then stop complaining,
(laughter)
Just eat your damn soft serve.
- In Japan as well,
for some reason, Baskin-Robbins
is referred to as 31.
Why, what's up with that?
Who made this?
- It's because Baskin-Robbins,
I think might be
too difficult to pronounce.
- Yeah, too long.
- 'Cause I remember I
showed my Japanese cousin,
'cause she loves 31 ice cream,
(in foreign language) as they call it.
And when I heard her
first say that, I was like
"31, what's that?
"That must be a Japanese
brand or something
"that I don't know."
I'm like, "Yeah let's go to 31 ice cream."
And I went and it's a Baskin-Robbins.
(talk over each other)
It's just a fucking Baskin-Robbins.
And I'm like, "You mean Baskin-Robbins?
"Yeah, we have that.
And she's like, "Baskin what?"
And I'm like, "It says it right there."
(laughter)
"In English." (laughter)
- We just highlight the 31 part.
- If anything, it's harder to see the 31,
than you see the Baskin-Robbins.
- Because at the corner,
it just says 31.
- But I'm like, "Do you clearly
not see that on either side
of the three and the one
it says Baskin-Robbins?"
And she's like, "Oh my God,
"I never saw that."
It's like 31 is 5% of the logo.
- That's crazy."
- And you're just completely disregarding
the other 95% of the logo.
The Japanese love to do
that though, don't they?
They love to take Western brands
but completely change the name of it,
just to fit their like way of things.
I love how
in Japan, they don't call
Mercedes-Benz, Mercedes-Benz.
They just call it Bensu.
- Bemz?
- You know what they call
a Mercedes-Benz in Japan?
- Because they can't pronounce Mercedes.
'Cause when I said that,
they were like, "What is Benz?
"Benz is an acronym?
"Benz is short for something?"
And I'm like, "Yeah. It's Mercedes-Benz."
Their minds were just blown.
They were like, "Mercedes,
where did that come from?"
- I wanna know the conversation
where Mercedes-Benz came up.
That feels like a code word
for something I would never say
like if I need help, Mercedes-Benz.
(laughter)
- No, because it was in
the same conversation
of when I told my cousin that 31
is called Baskin-Robbins.
- You were just speed running the-
- So I had to make sure I was like,
"What do you call Mercedes-Benz?"
'Cause I guess I just saw a Mercedes-Benz.
- What do you call a
quarter of pound of cheese.
- Quarter pound with cheese.
- Maybe we try to keep the
same name, like Ben & Jerry's.
Kinda like you guys try to keep,
not you guys, but anime in general,
we just call it cheese.
But now we have the same title.
We have the same OPs and ending songs.
- What do you think about the other way?
How some anime series
completely change the name
of the anime to fit the American way?
What do you think about
how Detective Conan
is called Case Closed?
- I understand the name Conan
it means-
- It is, isn't it?
Why?
- Why not just Detective Conan?
- It's because of the host
that's too famous in the State.
- The hostage?
- Conan.
The talk show host.
- Yeah, the talk show host.
- Detective Conan.
- And also the characters name
that Schwarzenegger played
back in the '90s. (talk over each other)
- Conan the Barbarian.
- People had Conan as him in English.
- That's fair enough.
At the time, I think,
it was coming around,
they were really big.
- Detective Conan O'Brien.
(laughter)
I wanna see that now.
- I wanna see that show
when he becomes detective.
- I think we have to change the name
of a certain child back.
Was it from Germany?
In Japan, we called him Tantan.
Tantan is a boy who got a dog with him.
- It's Tintin?
- Yes.
But Tintin sounds like a
male genitalia in Japanese.
(laughter)
- I know that.
- That makes sense though.
- So we got our own reasons.
- That's why me and my Japanese friends
used to refer to the
male genitalia as a joke
because we didn't wanna say
the actual thing in public.
So when we were in public we
would just be like Tintin.
I'm curious.
'Cause you've obviously been anime
and manga fan your whole life,
wat do you think about,
especially recently in the West,
it's gotten really popular.
Everyone's like, "I love anime."
What do you think of, I guess,
it getting bigger and all that?
- I'm happy.
At first, I thought some anime
titles that Western people
know must be only Naruto and
Dragon Ball and that's it.
But it's not true.
They actually know and
they actually get to watch
the same title at the same
time with English sub.
- To be fair, a large
majority of anime fans
still only watch Naruto and Dragon Ball.
- That's a huge group.
- Some people never get out of that phase
and then some people
they now they just watch
everything, like me, I guess.
- As you said, before I
think the general idea
of a Western anime fan
was like, "I love Naruto.
"I love Dragon Ball.
"I love One Piece."
And then that was it.
- What was the first US con you went to
or your first experience of-
- It was actually AX so the biggest one.
- That's a common go-to.
- I don't even think AX really counts.
It's not really representative
of a lot of other US conventions.
Because
AX is so big that it's a whole different
experience from most other conventions.
- You've got a lot of
Japanese industry people,
so you hear a lot of Japanese at AX.
Yeah, definitely.
- Have you ever been to the smaller cons?
- Yes, I have.
So that was completely different.
Some cons are just fan-based,
no industry people there.
- Very unorganized.
Every single time I've
been a guest at a con
something has gone horribly wrong
with my flight, my hotel.
- I think I've been pretty lucky.
I've had a few cons where it was horrible.
But a lot of the times,
especially the small cons,
I have more fun at a smaller
con than say the others.
- If I get there.
One time, this con booked me
months in advance.
And I don't think they'd ever
had an international guest.
So I told them like,
"Hey, you should book flight soon
'cause you're in the middle
of nowhere in the US."
It was in Indiana.
I was like, "You need to book flights.
"'cause they don't happen
a lot from the UK."
They didn't until one week before.
And then I had to go on
a 35 hour flight path.
- 35?
- It should have been
14 at most.
- That was the cheapest
flight they could find.
- That was the cheapest one.
I asked them, I was like, "How much was
"the other one that was,
I think it was 12 hours?"
It's still long
flight path.
And they were like, "It
was 150 bucks more."
And I'm like, "Are you kidding me?"
- Why did you agree to this?
- I already signed the
contract before that
'cause they said they were
gonna buy the flights.
And I thought they wouldn't do that to me.
(talk over each other)
That's a real rare moment there.
- They wouldn't expect me
to turn up on my flight
and then immediately do a panel
within 30 minutes of arriving.
And they did, they expected me to do that.
- I've done that before.
- And the worst part is
they booked me a hotel
the night before that I missed
because the 35 hour flight path.
I'm pretty sure that hotel
room cost more than $150.
So fuck you, that con.
(laughter)
- Every con's in Indiana
now is just sweating.
- I've been to a bunch in Indiana
and I've had a lot of the worst
experiences on that one con.
- Why is it Indiana of all states?
- I don't know why
I've been to a lot of cons
in Indiana, for some reason.
I went to one in Indiana,
which was Indy PopCon.
That one was actually quite fun.
I had a lot of fun with that one.
Well first, it wasn't
really an anime convention.
It was more like a YouTuber convention.
So I think they were a
lot more used to getting
all sorts of overseas guests.
- Was your agent doing all
of that for you, the cons
or was it you negotiating with them?
- At AX, I was just an industry guest.
So I was at a booth with other people.
But at the smaller con I was a guest.
So I got somebody from the
con with me all the time.
- You had a handler.
- I feel like 'cause I spoke English
they all left me to my own devices.
They were like, "Fuck it, just turn up.
"We just expect you to be here."
- I remember my first
time being a proper guest
at a convention, I think
it was Crunchyroll expo
because I had been guest before.
But I remember that my first experience
at Crunchyroll expo,
they gave me a handler.
I'd had no experience.
- What I do with you?
(laughter)
- He would just follow me around.
And I would just feel so awkward.
I would just be like-
- Can you not?
- I literally had to ask him to like,
"Can you just chill?"
'Cause I've heard a lot of
horror stories, so I get it now.
But back then it was my first experience.
So I'm like, "Dude, can
you just leave me alone?
"I'm all good. I don't need any help.
"I'm just walking around the con floor."
- I feel bad every time I
wanted to go to bathroom
because they have to follow me.
And I'm like, "I'm sorry
I have a smaller bladder.
"Sorry, I wanna go again."
- I'm just very used to being left
to my own devices as well.
- I think it's a very
British thing as well.
You're like, "I don't
want someone helping me.
"I can do it on my own."
- I think it's because I've had
my fair share of really good handlers
and just really useless handlers.
I know how to use my handler now.
(laughter)
- I know how to use you
and abuse you if I want.
(talk over each other)
- I know how to maximize my handler.
You know what I mean?
- I'm gonna min-max this shit.
- Joey turns up and he just gives him
a fucking 10 page survey.
He's like, "Fill this
out, I need to know."
- Where's my Dom Perignon,
the moment I land, come on guys.
- Can I speak to you?
I'm like, "This is bullshit."
Joey's had really good experiences.
And I feel like at least
half of my conventions
that weren't AX had something massive.
- It's really weird.
You hear a lot of horror stories about AX
from a lot of different people.
I don't think I've had
a horrible experience at AX.
But I think it's also because my schedule,
I purposely fill up my schedule
with as shit much to do
so that I don't leave
enough room for error.
Because a lot of people are like,
"I'm gonna space everything out.
"And then give myself some
time in between each thing."
But I'm like, "No, that's
where the horror happens."
It's the in between part
where you're left on your own.
You're like, "Well, I guess I'll go
"to the convention hall now."
And then horrible things
happen at the convention hall.
- AX has always been the
super, super busy convention.
Everyone's always busy.
Everyone's always doing something.
What is your schedule like in AX?
- I was signing.
In the first year, they gave
me a 30 minutes break each.
30 minutes isn't enough.
I wanna take off my wig
'cause everything's cosplay.
So I wanna take off my wig and
shut myself
in a bathroom stall
or be myself.
I just wanna take a rest.
But I couldn't take a rest.
I didn't want anyone to
see me without a wig.
That would look horrible.
- Unthinkable.
Taking off a wig? No.
- Disgusting.
- I just kept myself confided
in the stall, one stall.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
And I took Asprin every single time.
- I guess if you have
like a wig cap, that's
stretching your head.
- At some point I wanted stronger meds.
So I had to like, "Could
you buy something?"
- Give me meds.
- In the States, I'm sure
they got stronger ones.
Give me that.
- I've never cosplayed before.
And part of the reason is it feels like
at a convention wearing a cosplay
is a lot of effort and work
to keep it intact.
- I cosplayed once and that was at AX.
And I cosplayed as Gintoki from Gintama.
And I chose Gintoki
not only because I like
Gintoki as a character
but also because his stuff is light.
It's a little more breathable.
It's not like I'm wearing
a full suit of armor.
So I'm like, "It's really hot.
"This is a little bit breathable."
I didn't take into account
that I'd be wearing a
massive fucking white wig
like Gintoki does.
- That immediately is
a heating thing on your head.
- And because this part got so hot,
it completely
negated
the free flowing clothes
that I was wearing.
I remember I was in the
middle of a signing.
I'm like, "I'm sorry, I can't."
I just took it off.
And I'm like, "I'm sorry.
Fuck the hair, I can't do it."
I was like, "I don't care anymore.
"I'm gonna take it off.
It's so hot in here."
- I see some people in AX turning,
rocking up in a full
Guts armor or something.
I'm like, "How the fuck are you doing it?
"It's 33 degrees Celsius here right now."
- I guess if you just
restrict all your pores,
you can't sweat.
It can't come out.
You can't come out.
(talk over each other)
- Very impressive.
- That's why I wore a Virgin-Killer
sweater at AX one time.
- That's breathable, right?
(talk over each other)
- Is that why you like cosplaying as girls
because it's a breathable skirt?
- I love skirts because
you can free flow.
- You love skirts?
I feel like I can stretch my full stretch.
You know what I mean?
- But you didn't get stopped by security.
- No.
- Too much skin.
- In LA, it's normal.
I just went anything goes
in LA especially around AX.
- I remember I got in the Uber
and was seated with a guy.
And the moment I sat in, he was like,
"You're going to the
LA convention center?"
(laughter)
And I was like, "Yup, that's me."
- They know now it's become a routine now.
- And we didn't say anything.
It was the most awkward thing.
I was sitting there in the
back, like, "All right."
Were you in a skirt at that time?
- I was wearing the Virgin-Killer sweater.
(laughter)
I was cross-legged in the taxi like this,
straddling my feet.
(talk over each other)
- I'm just crossing my legs.
- You should have done the
Basic Instincts leg switch.
(laughter)
And then when he turns around like-
- Like, "Ooh, hello."
- I loved getting stopped by people.
Like, "Can I take photos with you?"
When you're a cosplayer that...
I think the most popular cosplay at AX
was Prison School that I wore.
- That was, not the
president, the vice president.
- I think that was last year.
And one of the reasons I bet
because it wasn't the
year for Prison School.
So there weren't a lot of
Prison School cosplays.
Most of them were wearing
Tamamo or Fate characters.
- As it always is.
- So I guess I stood out.
And some father asked me,
"Could you take a photo with my son?"
And his son was tiny.
- Did the son know what the series was?
- Maybe it's the kid on the plane.
- Oh my god, he probably was. (laughter)
- Garnt watched Prison School on a plane
and there was a tiny kid next to him
It was that kid.
He's like, "I love that show.
"I saw it on a plane."
(laughter)
- Was that a plane to AX?
- We talked about this before,
I normally watch some shitty,
I always have an anime photo
on my tablet.
Never watched that.
Always watch shitty plane
movies most of the time.
What's your favorite
cosplay that you'd say?
Or is that like picking your children?
- Can you name top five cosplays?
- Actually, next week I'm doing
my favorite character
from Final Fantasy VII.
I've done Yuffie already
for obvious reasons.
That's the most popular female character.
And if you've got a chance
with that, go for it.
But my favorite,
is Yuffie.
I just wanted to cosplay Yuffie.
So I finally get to do that
next week, plus Cowboy Bebop.
- Joe Valentine.
- Not Joe Valentine, sorry
- Faye Valentine.
- That's it, that's the
less than evil character.
Faye Valentine.
- What was your very first cosplay?
- My own, right?
- The Granblue Fantasy one?
- That was fourth.
Well, could be Super Sonico.
I have no idea.
(talk over each other)
- I can see that happening.
- That was also for me
as an industry guest.
Actually,
a boost too.
So I don't know.
my first,
one of my own choice,
I don't know.
What was that?
I did Mamako from-
- From Her Two-Hit Attack.
- Do you like your mother?
(laughter)
And Multi-attack.
- That was such a terrible show.
- We've talked about them before.
- I think my favorite cosplay
that you've ever done was,
I think it was at AX last year.
You did Trish Una, right?
- Yes, I did.
- Your Trish cosplay
was really, really good.
That was cool.
- I'm obsessed with JoJo's.
- We're all. We all love JoJo.
Speaking of JoJo, you have
like the JoJo kimono, right?
- Yes.
That thing is so cool.
- I ordered that in Osaka.
- I would have ordered that.
I don't care how much
it was, I'd have paid.
Not even a question.
- I'm gonna find out own Yahoo auction
and (talk over each other)
- That's where I get most
of my JoJo merch from.
I'm using Google translate
hoping I'm not clicking the
wrong things when I'm there.
- Connor's become that stamp
collector but for JoJo's
His grandkids are gonna be like.
"What is all this?"
- When I have a call with my parents,
all my merchs are behind me,
like, "What are those toys?"
"Connor, what are those toys?"
Like, "It's not a toy, mum.
"This is a one sixth gyro Zeppeli $200.
"Are you kidding me, mum?"
- You bust out of the osu.
Like "You don't understand how pristine
this thing is right now."
- I love getting deals
for JoJo stuff so much.
- I also got JoJo smartphone,
which I never use.
- JoJo smartphone?
- Yes, there is, JoJo's
- Not a smartphone skin,
an actual smartphone?
- Yeah, smartphone from Docomo.
- What?
This exists?
Where can I get one?
Are they on Yahoo?
It's probably on Yahoo Auction.
There's so much JoJo merch,
stuff blows my mind.
I spend way too much time
looking for JoJo merch.
I know there's websites that are dedicated
to tracking the release of new JoJo merch.
- Really?
- Yeah. And I kind of go,
'cause they release so much all the time,
which is great, being a fan.
But sometimes there's stuff that's like-
- When would you ever use it?
- There was one that was Rohan Kishibe
tiny jigsaw puzzle.
They're tiny, They're like this.
And I was like, "I mean."
- A four piece jigsaw puzzle.
- What's the point?
I'm never gonna be able to open this
'cause I'll be scared
to like actually do it.
- 'Cause you might lose a piece.
- How many pieces was it?
- It was something like 16.
(talk over each other)
- It's barely a puzzle.
- Then there's other stuff.
I have no interest in clear
files, but I think Japanese do.
- I don't know why the
clear files is the default.
We're gonna release a merchandise
to do with this show.
Let's make clear files.
- Because it's so cheap to manufacture.
- It's like the YouTuber first
t-shirt that's a reference.
They put He, he XT.
- It seems like the most tacky thing ever.
I've never bought a clear file
but I've always been given
them as a gift or something.
And I don't know what to
do with them, honestly.
I have a bunch of clear
files, but I've bought it,
It's so ironic.
I bought a file for my
clear files. (laughter)
- Which defeats the whole purpose.
(talk over each other)
They're actually custom-made clear file
or sometimes files for your
clear files because people know
that no one actually uses the clear files.
And they just treat it as
a piece of art or whatever.
They don't wanna use it
but they need some place
to easily access it.
And I found one and they sell it
at Dyson and stuff like that
for a hundred Yen.
So I just bought one.
- What don't they sell at Dyson?
And so I put all of my,
because I have a lot
of Monogatari series clear files.
Because if I find something Monogatari
I'm gonna buy it.
So I just put all my
Monogatari clear files
into my clear file file.
- To explain, Dyson is like
the dollar store here in Japan
where you can get
everything you didn't need.
every little contraption you
didn't know that you needed
until you go to the store that's Dyson.
- Literally anything
you need for your house
you can find it at Dyson.
- They have everything.
- It's nuts.
- Just so much useless stuff.
- So how many files could
you file in the file?
- I think the one I
bought you can put in 20.
- Just 20.
- That's not a lot.
- Joey, you can write
this down. (laughter)
- 20.
- It's nice.
It's better than having
all the clear files scattered everywhere.
At least it's in one spot.
- Just don't buy clear files. (laughter)
- Please stop making them, companies.
We don't care.
We really don't care.
- We're not gonna file anything.
- You have limited room.
You need to pick your merch carefully.
And when people are like,
"Man, why is Connor being
mean about a $10 figure?
I'm like, "It takes up space."
That space is for the expensive voice.
- Connor trying to maximize this shit.
- I'm trying to make like
the expensive JoJo cabinet.
- You're doing a good job so far.
- I know.
I'm collecting slowly.
- You're no JoJo Bar level, but...
- No, that guy's been
collecting for decades.
- Have you been to the JoJo bar?
- Which one?
- The one in Nakano.
- Is it still open?
- I think so, yeah, it's still open.
Just reopened.
- 'Cause the quarantine
(talk over each other)
- They were closed for a long time, but
I think they recently just
started reopening again.
'Cause I went there for a video
and the collection there is nuts.
I saw so many figurines
that I was like, "Wow, I didn't know
"they made a figurine of this character."
He had that really limited JoJo,
it was
Jotaro the Swarovski one.
So it's full on diamond encrusted Jotaro.
I looked it up on Yahoo
auction, it's $4,000.
And he just had a one on a pedestal.
- That sounds amazing.
I was like, "Oh my God, I need it."
- I wanna get it.
- Connor is about to
spend more money on JoJo.
I'm like, "Wallet forgive me
for what I'm about to do."
I have to not go on Yahoo auction
'cause I will end up buying something.
- That's why I never made
an account on Yahoo auctions
'cause I know I'm gonna
spend so much money on it.
- What about Mercari?
- Mercari, yeah I did.
But I think it was a little harder to use
they didn't accept my cards and stuff.
But I was like, "Nope."
- You probably need a
Japanese card, from up here?
- I do have a Japanese card now.
- You do?
- Yeah.
- I still don't.
- It's so hard to get a credit
card or a debit card here.
I don't know what banks want.
I dunno how you got accepted
either because I got rejected.
- I got rejected the first time,
but in the UK they just
basically give you a card.
They're like, "Yeah, take it."
- You just press this button
and they'll just send it to you.
- You don't really need credit?
- For debit card, no.
So they rejected me for a credit card
which I only thought
there was credit cards.
And then I got a debit card
but I needed someone
to help me fill it out
because they don't offer
English ones, forms.
So I was like, "Well, I'm fucked.
"What do I do?
"I wanna access my money."
'Cause I was using my foreign
card for the longest time.
God damn.
- I've got a question for you though.
What'd you think about the
whole new simp movement
that's just started in the Western sphere?
- What do you guys feel when
somebody call you a simp?
(talk over each other)
- I've been called a simp.
If I sent anything positive
at all, like, "Good job."
They'll be like, "Wow,
you're a simp, Connor,
"You just said nice
thing to a woman, simp."
I feel like the term simp
has been used so much
that nobody even knows what the original
meaning of the word simp was.
- Sometimes the right meaning just
calling your name kind of thing.
My
mod on Twitch had to ban the term simp.
(laughter)
I was gonna ask you that.
I swear, I never saw the
word simp in your channel.
- They're very protective of me.
- It's because everyone in the chat
knows that they're a simp.
So they're like, "We all
know why we're here, guys.
"We're all simping for Kaho."
I don't understand that term anymore.
The internet does what
the internet does best
and completely destroys
the meaning of a word
the moment it goes mainstream.
- 'Cause now it's like
if you give a female
any attention you're simping.
We're probably simping you right now
just by talking to you.
- I'm sure you're gonna meet
a lot of simp words in
the comment section.
We can bet.
We can make a bet how many.
- How dare they get a woman as a guest?
They're simping so hard.
- Now that we blacklisted
all the incognito comments,
every comment now is gonna be
simp comments now obviously.
- I don't know if it's
such as a joke thing
we can laugh about it or
you do feel uncomfortable
actually getting called simp.
- We're clowns.
- We're clowns so it's
part of the joke for us.
- I think the only people
who are uncomfortable
with being called a simp are actual simps.
You know what I mean?
They're like, "How dare you call me out?"
- When he term thicc, T-H-I-
- Thicc.
- The two Cs.
- Yeah, two Cs, it came out.
I saw it was malicious
or maybe negative term
for a second because it's thick.
(talk over each other)
So I saw it's just another
term for fat so fatty.
- But if it ends with a
K, then it's malicious.
If it ends the C, then it's complimentary.
- To seize it, it means your butt is big.
- At first, I didn't know this.
So they were commenting
like, "You're very thicc."
"How should I take that?"
(laughter)
I can see how that can
completely slip under.
Again, that's another example.
The word thicc is used so much now
that I see guys calling girls
thicc that aren't thicc.
They're not thicc at all.
- You have skin? That's thicc.
- I can't see your rib cage.
Damn, you're thicc.
It's like, "No, there's a difference
between thicc and just being healthy."
It's like cringe as well.
The word cringe.
- I hate the word cringe so much.
- 'Cause at first, again cringe
actually meant something.
People didn't like it.
But then everybody just starts to be like,
"That's cringe. That's
cringe. That's cringe."
- I remember people would be like,
whenever someone made a joke,
people would be like,
"That's pretty cringe but I laughed."
And I'm like, "Are you
trying to compliment me?
"I don't get it.
"Was that a compliment or an insult?
"I literally don't know anymore."
- The biggest oxymoron, isn't it?
It's cringe but I laughed.
I'm like, "Say that again but slowly."
- As a non-native speaker,
at first, I didn't know
it was a bad-ass thing.
It says ass but it's a good term.
If it's half ass it's not good.
You just have to learn.
- That's it.
That's what everyone wanted to know.
Because you do stream to an
English speaking audience,
how did you come to learn
all of the English internet terminology
because it's completely
different to the Japanese one?
- Sometimes I ask my chat like,
"What does that mean?"
- That's a dangerous game.
- My chat is very good.
- That's good.
- My chat is very educational
and they're very nice people.
- You have a very rare Twitch audience.
- My chat just wants
to see me fail, always.
I remember asking them,
I was playing a game.
I wanted to know the ping of the game.
I'm like, "What's the ping?"
And they were like, "It's OF4."
And I just thought, "Okay, OF4."
I closed the game in a ranked match.
I'm such an idiot. Sorry, go ahead.
- It's okay.
Because English, isn't my first language.
'Cause sometimes people try to correct me
even though it's just obviously a typo.
On Twitter especially,
you cannot edit a feed.
It's obviously a typo.
- I saw people were
correcting your English.
- That was Lafter cosplay. Sorry.
I was in the cosplay of Lafter character
from Iron-Blooded Orphans, Gundam.
And I was obviously in a cosplay
'cause of brown hair, green eyes.
And I always like to make puns
or whenever I post cosplay photos
I like to stay something
that belongs to the caption.
We're having COVID 19.
Why don't I just use a term
laughter is a good medicine.
But I put the laughter as Lafter.
(talk over each other)
And some people corrected me.
"That's the wrong spelling, bitch."
"Damn bitch, -."
- But on Twitter, there's
always that one also
'cause we make typos all the time.
And even if you delete
your tweet, immediately
they screenshot it.
They fucking send it to you.
"Excuse me, I have this typo by Gigguk.
"I know you're trying to hide."
- I think that is my
absolute biggest pet peeve.
It's two in the morning and I'm like,
"I'm just gonna tweet something
funny," and then I tweet it.
10 seconds later I realize there's a typo.
I'm like, "No one probably saw that."
Delete it.
And then maybe a couple minutes later
I do it again but the correct spelling.
The first 10 comments is always,
"I saw that."
- Joey exposed for making a typo.
- Joey doesn't know how to spell.
And I'm like, "Fuck off."
- So it happens to everybody?
- Yeah.
- Who are these people?
This is a call-out by the way who are you?
What do you get out of this?
- Were you waiting for
me to tweet, to catch it?
It's like Chris Hansen.
It's like, "I got him."
(laughter)
- Did you think you were the only person
who got called out for typos?
- Yeah, because it's English,
it's not my first language.
- That's more of an argument
of why we should get it right.
- Because it's our first language.
So we don't have an excuse.
At least you have the excuse
that it's not your first language.
- Maybe I should have quoted, Lafter.
But I didn't want to make it obvious.
- The joke's not funny if you have to.
- It's a joke, please laugh.
- It's that ironic situation where
the person correcting you thinks
that you're more intelligent about it
when you made a very intelligent joke
that they just don't understand that.
- And if you were smart
enough that you can just guess
I'm obviously wearing golden hair,
green eyes which aren't obviously mine.
You could guess maybe
it has something to do
with cosplay because I know
the spelling of laughter.
(laughter)
I know that my English isn't impeccable
but at least they know
the term impeccable.
That says something about my English.
- That's more than most English people.
- Please, people.
But I do sometimes make mistakes,
some words sound similar,
like testicles, tentacles,
I sometimes mistake.
But they both belong to Hentai
so they can be mistaken.
- So everyday words.
- I make a good laugh though.
- Do you ever get any toxicity online
for being in your position
or anything like that?
- For being an actress?
- Most cosplayers I know have again
a lot of toxicity, let alone
people who worked in JAV.
- Dick pics.
- Do you get a lot of dick pics?
- I closed my DM.
It's only for my friends.
(talk over each other)
- That's a good idea.
- A sane mind would do.
- I also close my Instagram DM
but somehow, they always miss.
There are some messages
from someone I don't know.
- Really? Weird.
- I guess somebody was that desperate
for you to see their dick.
- "I've hacked the mainframe.
"I need you to see my penis.
"I'm willing to go to jail."
- Instagram had a bug, I think.
- Closing DMs on Twitter and Instagram
is step one of creating an account.
- Yeah.
- No girls appreciate a dick pic.
I can just state out.
- You heard it here first.
- No one.
Well maybe if we get to know you better.
- Or size them up?
- Guys, you've got her known first.
- Before you shoot a porno were they like,
"Here it is.
"Here's the package."
- "I wanna be a main actor in JAV."
"How do you go at it?
"Here is my pic."
Where's your face?
- You should reply to
them, "It's two out of 10."
Just ruin that.
- You should reply back being like,
"Listen, honey I've done porn before,
"this is weak.
"This penis is weak."
And then they'll probably
stop doing it after that.
- Well, they're gonna be haters maybe.
- Who needs them?
- Do you really want people who
send unsolicited dick
pics to be your fans?
Did you want that kind of audience?
- I don't want that.
- That's a level of simping I don't want.
- You're like, "Geez, I wish I had someone
"to send my penis to."
I'm curious, going off something like that
and online, I feel like
you almost have no privacy.
And the people wanna know
everything about you.
Do you get a lot of people
who really wanna find
out your personal life?
And also I'm also
curious as well with JAV,
how much did they have a say over
what you could do in your free time,
relationships and stuff?
Did they have any say over that?
- Most girls, not just JAV actresses,
but talents in general in Japan,
they try to hide their
relationship status.
They pretend it's for their
fans or maybe for them.
Because if you say you got a girlfriend
or you got a boyfriend then sometimes
your fan base grows smaller.
That happens a lot.
- That's really strange 'cause
I feel like in the West,
we don't really do that.
- It happens on YouTube.
I know I lost a massive female audience
when I came out about Aki.
- Seriously?
- Yeah, I did.
- And subsequently, Aki also
lost a large male audience.
- You guys could see that in the stats?
- Yeah, we saw it in the stats.
- I have no idea that happened.
- It's recovered now for the both of us.
We're back to 50, 50 male to female.
But when we first came out, I
think I had an 80% male ratio
and Aki had 80% female ratio
just because I guess all the simps left.
(laughter)
'Cause it's like, "Damn, we
have to find the next target."
It came back obviously.
I assume it's the same thing.
- I think it's very different
especially in the Japanese industry
where they have this obsession
with keeping a pure image
even more than the West
especially in the idol industry.
That's on a level I will never understand.
- If you're allowed to
tell us, you don't have to,
but if it's too personal, it's fine.
Did you ever try and date
after or during the period?
How was that when you like-
- Not during it, because-
- It's hard to if you're like,
"Hey, I'm going to work."
- I would feel bad about it.
There are a lot of
actresses who were dating,
who were in a relationship
but I didn't know how they cope with it.
- It's a bit like, "Bye
honey, I'm gonna have sex."
(laughter)
- And they hated dating actors.
So they understand the pain
of your significant other doing the job.
And some of them dated actors too.
They were always fighting because of that.
- Wow.
- So how small is the industry?
Did you know a lot of people
working in the industry?
When you worked with
other actors or actresses,
did you already know them personally?
Or was it someone you met on the day?
- Actors, most, I never got
to know them personally.
Maybe just on social media.
How do I say?
They're
nicer,
I don't know.
Not compared to anybody,
they're nicer on words.
- Let them know.
- New male actors they want
us to request, make a request,
I want this actor on this
set, that kind of thing.
So that's why some of them
are obviously sucking up
to you but in a good way.
Like me bringing you all those gifts.
(laughter)
- No, obviously.
- Yes, of course.
Because actors are all
freelancers,
they can get hired anytime.
They don't have management
companies behind you.
The guys?
- Guys.
Their payment are lower than ours.
- Just like in the West.
- In our mind, men are
happily in the industry
whereas women sometimes
they have to do this.
- So basically, all the
women have the power
to choose who they wanna work with.
So you gotta be good at socializing
and making network connections
if you're a male porn actor then.
- Male porn actors they have to do more.
They usually just,
"I saw you on Twitter."
They check our name and can do
some research before we meet.
We rarely got to know them, I guess.
That's like real life, isn't it?
If you wanna be associated with someone,
don't be a dick, don't be an asshole
and you'll probably be
associated with them.
I wanted to know actually,
and I know this is
gonna get a bit weird.
But you know how there's a type of JAV
and this is only in JAV,
but it's the creepy dude.
- We call it the ugly
bustard, I think, in the West.
- I've always wanted to know,
well, first of all, have you ever done
anything like that, in that genre?
And if you have,
what are the actors like in real life?
I've always wanted to know.
- They're 50 year old men looking
- And they purposely have to act creepy.
- We actually need them in the industry.
(laughter)
Here's why.
It's not me saying it but the directors
and the staff members,
producers say because-
- The people watching.
- -people can relate to them.
- Oh my God, it's true.
It's true.
- I'd always heard this, but I was like,
"No, that can't be it."
- People can identify
with them either way.
Some people want that.
(talk over each other)
- Like doujinshi, there
are some handsome guys
and beautiful, always beautiful women
but sometimes there are-
- Most of it is the ugly guy.
It's like a meme in our circles.
- I imagine though, did
you just get to that point
where you don't care, it's just work.
Or were you like, "Oh god, okay."
- I don't even hate any of them.
- Well, there must be some
days where you woke up
and you're like, "Oh, this?"
(laughter)
"I'm good at acting, I guess."
- "He looks way better
in the picture I got."
(laughter)
- "That head shot was some
20 years ago, don't lie."
- "He definitely uses the
Snow App on his headshot."
- Actually, guys who think,
who lack confidence in their body,
they're actually nicer to you.
They appreciate your work.
- That makes so much sense.
- If I wasn't an actor,
I wouldn't be able to-
- You're giving some people a
lot of confidence right now.
They're like, "That's
me. I can fuck good."
- "I can be an ugly bustard."
(laughter)
- Good-looking famous actors,
they tend to be dah, dah, dah.
- Assholes.
- It's like, "Whatever, I can
do this (talk over each other)
- I'm handsome, you're
happy with that, right?
Kind of thing.
- To think that the more handsome you are
the more egotistic you are,
who would have thought?
- To think that ugly bustards
are a wanted commodity
in the porn industry.
- There was actually one actor I think who
being around in the
industry more than 10 years,
so he's obviously experienced one,
and he's good-looking now.
He was like, "If I do this,
then you're gonna squirt."
What?
- What?
- Ribena?
(laughter)
- If I do that then you're gonna come."
No, I won't.
He's just overly confident.
(laughter)
- Come, come, come, come.
- No, no, no, no, no.
(laughter)
- If someone said that to me
like, "I have to fuck you now?
"You said that to me, are you serious?"
What is that like a mariachi band?
What the fuck's going on?
(laughter)
Oh my god.
- Could you imagine if
it was the opposite?
If you're about to like
have sex with a girl.
And she's like, when I do that-
she is all over me.
I'm like, "We'll see
about that, motherfucker."
- I can actually imagine
that with some people.
- That's some ideal relationship.
It's the whole Dom thing.
They're like, "Oh my god, yes."
- That's crazy.
To ruin the perception, I gotta ask
how much of
adult video is just faked?
- It totally depends on the work.
Sometime we fake,
we make a fake cum.
Have you guys seen the Asa-banana,
the drinking product?
- It's a banana flavored jelly.
- Yes.
- We actually use that for fake-
- Is that squirted on you?
- You insert that with-
- I gotta Google this.
- I'm never drinking that.
- I remember we briefly talked
about this in the interview.
You were saying that a lot of the fake cum
is the Asa-banana stuff,
but it's also milk and-
- Or egg white.
- Egg white,
to just get the consistency.
- They make sure you don't
have any food allergies.
(laughter)
- You turn up to your first porn gig,
"Any gluten allergies?"
And you're like "What?"
- "I need my cum gluten
free, thank you very much."
"As long as the cum is grass-fed."
(laughter)
"I think my Starbucks semi skimmed cum."
- I'm so sorry.
- It's okay.
If an actor won't come in the scene
and you can still use the
actor in the next scene.
You can save his cum.
You can save his energy.
- Is that how hentai protagonists have
just so much cum every time?
(talk over each other)
- Is this why all the
DVDs are three hours long?
They save it?
They're really long, two hours minimum.
Is that in one day?
Or is that like a multiple day thing?
- Usually, just one day
because renting a studio
is very expensive.
- Is it one actor the entire time?
- It depends on but sometimes they change
and they make it POB, so they
won't find out sometimes.
- I've seen best of, eight hours long.
And in my head, I'm like, "First of all,
"wow, that's a long shoot.
"Second of all, who is gonna sit down
"and watch eight hours of this?"
- They give me anxiety
trying to find the best part.
I'm like, "No, no."
- Is it made for people
with erectile dysfunction?
Where it's like, "Give me
two hours and I'll be there."
I just don't understand.
- They seem to think
the longer, the better.
- The longer the better.
- Wow, that's our YouTube video
- I need to get those mid-rolls.
(laughter)
- I wonder, did you ever
watch any of your own work?
Or
when you did it, you're like,
"I don't want anything to do with this."
- During my career, I did
watch some of my clips
for studying for research.
- Is it weird watching yourself?
- At first, it was so embarrassing.
'Cause I was like, "The light
doesn't maybe hit well."
(laughter)
- It's all wrong.
- This angle isn't for me at all.
(laughter)
- I love how you said that you watched
your own clips for research purposes.
That's the perfect word.
- 'Cause you wanna look good.
- Exactly. (talk over each other)
- That makes sense.
- I'm sure we do that, on YouTube.
We sometimes watch back on our old videos.
- I cringe.
I can't watch myself on camera.
Sometimes even on the podcast
I'm just cringing on myself.
- I used to not be able to.
And I think you get used to it more.
- Yeah, you get used to it.
- Sometimes you're like,
"Damn, that was a good video. (laughter)
"I love watching this part.
- Pat on the back.
Goddamn, I look good.
I look damn good.
- Whenever a funny joke comes up
and you're like, "Damn,
that was a good joke.
"God, I'm so funny."
You ever like that when you're watching?
Like, "I remember this part."
- Sometimes I just laughed,
those dirty words I just said.
(laughter)
That line was from this
Manga series. (laughter)
I personally go O2D when it comes to it,
when you release yourself.
I never watch porn, I
go for 2D all the time.
- Wait, before you ever got into porn
did you never watch porn to research?
- I was curious how they make the video.
That's why I wanted to get in.
I've never been a fan.
- This seems like a lot
of steps to watch porn.
- Now I'm curious now,
what titles did you read to
learn the vulgar language?
- Manga recommendations with
Shibuya Kaho. (laughter)
- It depends on the role I'm playing.
Sometime I'm a cabin
attendant, flight attendant.
So I pick all those doujinshi
about flight attendants and
pick up all those lines.
- There's doujinshi about everything.
If it exists, there's
(talk over each other)
- Or a nurse at a hospital.
- It's very common.
- I pick up some lines
from each and I just...
- Did you know if everyone did this?
or was this just you?
- It was just me, I guess. (laughter)
- How did other people learn to do it?
- I don't know.
- Maybe they watch porn?
- I like to make jokes, you know?
I don't know.
There was one thing,
if you're in a nurse cosplay
you have a needle and I'm
gonna put (indistinct).
Put a needle on you.
You got a huge needle or
that kind of injection or whatever.
You try to play with words.
Of course, I said it in Japanese,
it's hard to translate.
- Yeah.
- If you're a flight attendant,
have a nice flight.
Your sperm had a great flight
or something like that.
(laughter)
- Instead of saying you're coming.
But more like you're
taking off. (laughter)
That kind of thing.
- Did you ever burst out laughing
or couldn't keep a straight face?
- Actually, the director is there.
Ask me not to do that too often.
- Who knew that your real
career was in comedy all along?
- It's not so much you losing it,
just all the stuff.
It's like, "Good one."
That's hilarious.
- I like to do word phrases.
- Actually going off in hindsight,
you mentioned in Joey's
interview last time
that you were voice
acting in a Hendai soon.
I was very curious, one, if
you can talk about it now
and two, what the entire process is like.
- I assume it's not the
low budget Aero games
that these two were playing
when they were growing up.
- Hey man, don't don't get like that.
- We wanna know more about
this Hendai voice acting.
- However, the production has been delayed
because of COVID-19.
- So it was supposed to
come out sometime soon.
- We haven't filmed yet.
I had an audition and I got a role.
But we cannot film yet
because it includes a lot of mourning
and screaming. (laughter)
- It's supposed to be the final boss
versus rocking out.
- You cannot keep enough social
distance for that to do it.
- We wanna moan but we gotta
keep the six feet, dude.
- I imagine you going into that audition
was like Saitama going into
a kid's boxing tournament.
- It was like, "This is so easy.
"This is easy mode."
- It was so difficult at first.
'cause there are pictures already there.
That's the difference between
normal anime and hentai anime.
Because hentai anime,
they got all the pictures ready for you.
But normal, regular anime,
it's just a rough image.
So you can speak however you want
within this amount of time.
- So the hentai is fully complete.
- You have to match the-
- So all hentai is actually dubbed hentai?
- It's all dubbed.
It's all dubbed over.
- So you have to match the moans
and everything with what's
going on in the screen?
- With the lips too.
So that was hard.
- I feel that hentai voice actors
have it so much harder
than regular voice actors,
especially if you're female
because there are some
scenes that I'm like,
"Damn, this must be like
tolling on their throat."
From all the (screams) that they're doing.
- And you cannot get too into it because
the next scene could
be something different.
- Could be the biggest one.
(laughter)
- It could be an even bigger one.
I wouldn't know.
I don't watch any bad things.
- Yeah, of course.
- I think we can all agree that
it'd be cool if we could
like voice acting a hentai.
- I would love voice act.
- That would be great.
Just for the experience alone.
- My audience will never let me go for it.
But they'll probably never
take me seriously ever again.
- I've worked in a Yaoi
were I did a sex scene.
I haven't had anyone
bring it up to me, much.
- But that's because yours were 93%.
- True.
- I made my own.
No one would hire me to do Hentai.
So I was like, " Fuck it,
I'm gonna make my own."
You're gonna make your own.
- I made my won Yaoi
audiobook where I just moaned.
- Nice, audiobook.
- And you get to hear it,
surround sound. (laughter)
- 16 surround sound, (laughter)
Connor moaning.
- Did you ever shout come seven times?
- Come, come, come.
(laughter)
- No.
- When I was voicing it,
you would do it.
And you're like, I'm
already getting pretty loud.
And then like you said, you turn the page
and you're like, "I've got
to get louder than this?
"This is the climax?"
I've never had experience
having to screech
coming at the top of my lungs before
but he was in the manga so
I have to replicate that.
And I'm like, "It's a
very strange process."
'Cause it's so hard to
fake come that loud.
'Cause in real life I would
have a shout when coming.
- Because in real life,
you'd just be like...
(laughter)
- Also, I don't wanna disturb
my downstairs neighbors.
They're very elderly.
I don't wanna be, "I'm gonna knock."
(laughter)
My voice already travels
through walls very well.
- It's like the low vibrations
that travel through the walls.
- Did I tell you this guy?
One of my old houses,
the walls were so thin
that my voice had the same
natural frequency as the walls.
So when I spoke, they
would always vibrate.
(laughter)
It was horrible.
- You voice has a natural,
it naturally resonates everywhere.
- We've had comments every
now and then on the podcast
where people would like,
"I actually can't understand
what Connor is saying
because it's going sub (laughter)."
- Sometimes it sounds like mumbles.
'causw it's so deep.
It just sounds like (deep throat sound).
- Like a sub whiff.
- I can get lost in your voice.
Like, "I wasn't listening.
Your voice is just too great.
- Get outta here.
- I remember it was so weird
'cause when my voice broke,
I was 13 when I started
to sound like this.
Could you imagine like now?
- What did you sound like before?
- Very high-pitched.
- Really?
- It's always those ways
'cause I've seen some clips
of like the official movie trailer voices
and how they got that voice.
And apparently, every one of them
had really, really high voices.
And then they just dropped
like that one evening.
- People thought I was messing around,
They thought I was joking.
'Cause I used to do voices all the time,
(makes high pitched sound) way higher.
My voice was higher
Just do dumb voices.
So when I came into school
and my voice started getting like,
"Yo, yo, what up?" (in
a deep voice) (laughter)
People were like, "What the fuck?
"Is Connor faking this?'
"I was like, "No, I
don't know what happened.
"I think it's a sore throat or something
"but I'm sure I'll be fine."
A week later, I still have it.
And I'm like, "What the-?
- So did that just happen overnight?
- I think it happened
over like a week or two.
Is that how it happens?
I have no idea how it happened.
- I think mine just dropped immediately.
- I think it was like, it's like a snap.
DO you remember?
I don't remember now
that I think about it.
- No you got, because you
listen to your voice every day.
So the subtle differences, you can't hear.
So it's like," I guess
my voice is here now."
I didn't realize it.
- I used to scare the
youngest kids in the hallway.
I would walk behind them and
I'd be like, "Yo, you, what up?
(laughter)
"Yo."
And they would be. (laughter)
Then you just walking
like, "Hey, what's up?"
The moment you turn around
you should be like, "Hey"
- So you've done so much in your career
you've JAV, you've done journalism.
You're now doing cosplay.
You're writing a book and everything.
What's the next step for you?
You seem like you always wanna
be challenging and trying new things,
which is like,
we can all get behind that.
We all love trying new stuff.
So coming from someone who seemingly looks
like they've done everything,
what's the next step that you wanna do?
- I have just started streaming,
On Twitch because of the quarantine.
Because like, I don't have nowhere to go,
I love staying in.
But I love to go visit Western cons.
But of course that's not gonna happen
at least till next year.
- Till next year, probably.
- What is your Twitch, by the way?
Just so people can-
(talk over each other)
- Maybe it's gonna say it right here.
- Yeah. (laughter)
- In the link down below.
- She knows the editor will do this work.
- Shibuya_kaho.
- I watched some of your streams before
and they were really good.
You speak Japanese and
English on the stream as well.
- Mostly in English.
I picked English because
that's a good practice for me.
And I love going to cons
in overseas.
Because in Japan, I'm already,
again, a JAV actress and they
will not have a cosplayer
who are not
on that risky label.
because some Japanese cons
don't wanna touch that area.
That's not family friendly.
If you'll grab your idols.
It's fine.
- (talk over each other) being
very family or demonetized.
- If you grow here
if you wear piece team,
if you haven't seen areola, that's fine.
If you've seen every thing already
then that's no, no.
So there is no room for
me to be there, I guess.
I'm not gonna be needed there.
I love speaking English.
I love learning more.
And
I love how Otaku, how weeb,
how real weeb they were at AX.
I was so impressed by
every single one of them.
They are so open-minded
about every single genre too.
"Cause there are not a people,
a lot of Otakus in Japan,
weebs in Japan who focus
on one genre and that's it.
They're like, "I don't watch the show."
And don't even dare to
ask what the show is about
or maybe even shows interest.
"I never watched ever," and that's it.
That's the end of the conversation.
Maybe you can ask me-
- How dare they?
- AS we all grab our (talk
over each other) shirts.
- I'm wearing freaking Madoka.
But I love her though.
- I went to the boys love
section in a Manga store here
and I got so many looks.
All the women were like, "What
the fuck is he doing here?"
- I get that too every time Aki wants
to go buy like Kingdom Hearts doujinshis.
I'm like, "I shouldn't be here."
I feel really weird.
- You can feel I'm not welcome.
I'm in danger here.
- I sometimes get that
just from walking down
Otome Road in Ikebukuro.
Because Otome Road obviously
as the name implies
it's for Fujoshis and girl
are into that kind of stuff.
- But it's a public road.
- "Get off this public road."
- I legit get stares
from some other Fujoshis
who are like, "You don't belong here.
What are you doing?
You're this white male."
- "He's a male."
- "He's a male.
"He joined my gay porn?
"Get out of here."
I'm like, "It's a public road."
- "There's no males allowed
in gay porn, never."
You actually went to the Yaoi Cafe,
the boys love cafe.
- I actually sat exact the
same spot you were sitting.
- 'Cause you DM'd me saying,
"I'm going to tomorrow."
How was it? Did you enjoy it?
- It was interesting.
They're all wearing masks.
We could only see the eyes.
- If you don't know, I may
as well plug my own video,
go and watch the Yaoi
Cafe video. It's great.
It's where they basically reenact-
- You are blushed every second,
the whole episode.
- I was like, (pants)
- You were so rad.
- Because basically they pretty much act
BL scenes in front of you.
Have you been?
- I haven't.
But I've watched Aki's videos.
- As a Western person, it
doesn't work in my brain.
This thing is so (grunts)
- I had to translate some
of the skits in Aki's video
because they're doing it in Japanese.
And Aki's like, "I dunno
what they're saying.
"So can you translate this?"
And sitting there and watching the video
of the skits, I'm like, "Oh no."
- I watched Aki's video too.
- I'm like, "Oh my god, I can't."
We turned up and they were like,
"So what you want us to do?"
And I'm like,
"Do your thing.
"What do you normally do?"
- Just fuck, just do it.
We'll blur it out, just do it, just fuck.
- And they were like,
"Well, we can do a rice thing."
And I'm like, "Sure."
And they start doing it.
And I'm like, "Oh my
god, they're doing it."
- And I felt so bad for you 'cause
Aki was with her female friends.
- It's just me.
And they were all staring.
- You went all by yourself.
- The worst part was
that they would do it.
And they're like, "Are
you happy?" (laughter)
- "Did you like?"
- "Was that good enough?"
And I'm like, "Yeah, that was good."
- "Can you give us the like?"
- "Rating out of 10."
- And then they did the thing where they,
what's the thing where
your put your arm on-
- Kabedon.
- And they did that.
And I'm like, "This is cool and all
but can one of you hold
my Kermit the doll,
"Kermit the frog?"
I brought my Kermit the frog with me.
I was like, "Hey, maybe you could you-"
'Cause it's a little joke on my channel.
"Hey, maybe could you do something-"
The guy fucking grabs it,
shoves his hand inside Kermit
and is like, "We're gonna
do a scene with Kermit."
I didn't even go to say anything.
He fucking laser beamed onto this Kermit.
- It's like, "Finally,
something I can fist."
(laughter)
"These other employees don't let me.
- He was like, "What do
you want me to do with it?"
I'm like, "Dude, I..."
- "That's all you, man."
- I'm like, "This is all you, go ahead."
And then he was like,
"We'll do a scene with it."
And I'm dying.
I'm like, "Oh my god,
this is so embarrassing."
Because there's two cameras on me.
Everyone's like, "Is this
what you wanted, Connor?"
"Is this is the footage you wanted?"
I'm like,
"I guess, this is what I wanted."
It's one of the hardest
videos to sit through.
- For me, there was just something
about seeing real people acting
anime characters.
In anime, it just seems normal.
But when you see real
life people doing it,
sometimes going to a maid cafe is just oh.
- Don't talk about maid cafe's
I went once and once was all I needed.
- Which one?
- I went to-
- @Home Cafe?
- It was the one in Akihabara.
- Do you know them all?
Why are you familiar with them all?
- I got a friend who loves
them, male and female.
- I went to @Home in Akihabara.
- Quintessential.
- Because my friend who's a
huge fan of maid cafes was like,
"You've never been to a a maid cafe?"
"We should go.
"I know the best one, it's @Home."
I'm like, "All right."
And man, I've never been more disappointed
in a 2,000 Yen omurice in my life.
(laughter)
I'm like, "This thing costs 2,000 Yen?
"And it took 45 minutes to
come out and it's cold."
- And they put the spell on it.
- And they put a spell on it.
(talk over each other)
- They do the moe moe kyun spell.
And they force you to say it as well.
- And I'm like, "I don't need a spell.
"I need a microwave to heat this up."
(laughter)
"The spell isn't doing
anything but making it colder."
- I think the most awkward experience
in my life was having to do that.
I was dressed as a maid
and I had to do it at the airport.
And there was 10 businessmen
who were watching.
They were all not saying anything,
not laughing, whenever I did anything.
They would just stare.
It was horrible
because these girls are
really awkward as maids.
I thought they were
supposed to be like, "Wow."
But they were like...
And then I had to draw on the omurice.
I drew Sonik. (laughter)
With ketchup?
- Yeah, with ketchup.
- And it was like diffusing a bomb.
It was so tense in that room.
Everyone was silent while I was doing.
I'm sweating.
- That's torture.
- I'm like, "Can someone
break the silence,
do something funny?"
And whenever I made a joke, obviously,
'cause none of them could speak English,
they were like...
- To break the silence,
you should have been
under your breath be like,
(hums video game tune)
(laughter)
- So you like maid cafes?
- My friend love maid cafes.
I don't go there by myself.
I'm not that avid religious.
- Because there are some
religious people that go.
- There's people that
go to every maid cafe
and just rate every maid cafe.
Like, "This maid was pretty cute.
"She said moe moe kyun
"the way I wanted to hear it."
- It's different, that moe moe.
- That moe moe came a bit different.
- I saw a guy.
He's a guy in Japan who has reviewed
every Starbucks in Japan.
Every single Starbucks in
Japan, I think he's reviewed.
- Is he a Japanese?
- Japanese guy
I think there's plus 10,000.
- Jesus Christ.
I think that's all of the,
- Nearly all of them.
I think he's working his way through it.
He's still going but he's
done over half, I know.
- How different could they be?
- That's what I think.
I'm like, "You picked
the worst coffee chain."
- Is that about the customer servicing?
- I don't know.
- I understand if he went around to go
every independently-owned coffee shop
because there's little differences
but I'm pretty sure a
Starbucks in Hokkaido
is gonna be the same
Starbucks as in Okinawa.
- Maybe he cares about what the cup says
with the doodle.
- I'm gonna go to
Hokkaido to find that out.
So I noticed that you're
a huge fan of retro games.
- Yeah.
(talk over each other)
- Could you tell us some of
your favorite retro games?
I'm interested.
Or is that too hard?
- The one I played most
was Cedar Moon action game.
- Really?
- It's very, very Final Fightish.
- Is that the fighting game?
- No, it's action game.
It's exactly like final fight.
You just keep walking and
some- (talk over each other)
- Like Double Edged.
- We call in Japan,
belt score action game.
Keep going.
- I think my cousin had a collection,
'cause there was a number of them.
There was six or seven
of them on the forum.
- At least two family
game were action games
and one puzzle game, one RPG,
two fighting games.
There are a lot of titles.
- I saw you were streaming.
Island Galleon game you were streaming.
- I play the first PlayStation
ever game for PlayStation.
It was simulation game.
So you think you choose a certain
answer.
And that's gonna change the ending.
But actually, until the very end,
it's always the same.
Up to the very end this final stream
gonna let you choose three
paths and three endings.
(talk over each other)
- So it was basically
just mass effect then.
Your choices mean nothing.
- You know what?
You can't even skip
any stories.
You have to rewatch it again and again.
- That is the worst nightmare.
- That's my hell.
- I love the old Neo Geo games,
Metal Slug is my favorite series.
I fucking love Metal Slug.
- I recently just did a video
where I went and played
a bunch of Japan only
retro games, anime retro games.
Because there's a number
of JoJo games as well,
like Superfamily con and-
Hakirah
- And the Yu Yu Hakusho game.
- Dude, the Yu Yu Hakusho game was so fun.
But I didn't realize that
it's a really popular game in Japan.
No one in the West knows about it
because they only localized it.
Well, obviously they only released
in Japan and for some reason, Brazil.
But only Brazil.
The US didn't get it,
Europe didn't get it.
Australia didn't get it.
It was only Brazil that got it.
- There are maybe a lot of
Japanese Brazilians at the time.
- I found this out today actually.
The legendary professional
wrestler, Antonio Inoki.
He was from Brazil.
- That's right.
- Apparently there's a huge population
of Japanese in Brazil.
I can't remember the reason why .
- Anime is pretty big
in Brazil so I've heard.
Way bigger than it was,
where we grew up.
But it's just amazing how many anime games
there are that have just existed
that will never get translated.
Even some big ones still
have not been translated.
- 'Cause the Sierra Moon RPG one,
they just got fans out a few years ago
after all these years.
- The original Fate/Stay
night visual novel
has still not been officially translated.
Really?
- Yeah.
So anyone who's played the original
Fate/Stay night visual novel,
it's all fan translations right now.
And Fate fans expect people
to get people into it
by reading the visual novel.
- Because I know it was
really massive news.
I think it was like three
years ago when they decided
to make an official
like English translation
of the Clannad visual novel,
and they'd made a kickstarter
for it and everything.
And it got finished in less than 24 hours,
even though it's such an old game.
And it wasn't at that
point, I realized I'm like
"Oh, shit, there's never been
"an official translation of this game."
It's all fan subs.
And in my head, I'm like,
"Who is doing these fan subs?"
Who has so much time
(talk over each other)
and talent that you're
like, "You know what,
"there's this visual novel,'
"that's all dialogue,
"200 plus hours long.
"if you put into a script,
it's like 300, 400 pages.
"I'ma translate it."
How do you find yourself in that position?
- Weebs weaponized, man.
They're incredible.
- Weebs are so passionate.
- They are.
Was it Secret of Mana
that never got an official (indistinct)?
- The first one, yeah.
- Final Fantasy never got released,
even though it was a huge
series until very recently.
- Until very recently.
- Which is crazy to think, a
game series like Final Fantasy
that was killing it in the West as well.
One of them wasn't released.
That's crazy.
- It's really weird.
I have a lot of Mana's
fanatic friends in California,
especially, but I think the
only official one was Robotech.
Otherwise, you have to
look for them unofficially.
- It's hard being a weeb. It's hard.
- Especially a retro weeb
'cause now like Macross,
it's not got as big of
a fan base as it used to
because now Mecha has just almost died
in the Western fandom.
It's only the very dedicated
fans that still will keep
up with everything like that.
And if there is Mecha,
then it's usually combined
with some other genre
that is more appealing.
It's not usually Mecha is the main.
It's like, "Here is the main
"and we just add a little
bit of Mecha to it."
- I think the last big Mecha
was probably Dialing in the Franxx.
and I'm pretty sure more people cared
about Zero 2 than they cared about Mechs.
No one was like, "Darling in the FranXX,
"those mecchas are cool."
It was more like, Darling in the FranXX,
(talk over each other)
- They were looking inside.
- It's like, "Damn, that booty is thick."
That's all they cared about.
- We missed out on so many
good porn parodies, Japan
because of your dumb laws
of Darling in the FranXX.
Yeah. Oh my God.
- I'm surprised they haven't made
a Darling in the FranXX porn yet.
Or in fact, so many anime series
or manga series that could
easily make a porn parody.
And I know it will sell.
- Well, American porn producers who listen
to Trash Taste, please make it happen.
- Amen. We just gave you
guys free real estate.
- Yeah, exactly.
- 'Cause you know people
are gonna buy that shit
if they make it in the West.
- Macross, for example my
friend actually organized
Macross convention, one day convention.
It's called super dimension con.
That's how much they love.
- Is that in America?
- Yes.
In California, I think.
That's amazing that even though
we didn't have an access
to the official ones.
And also, I've noticed
that there are a lot
of super fans in the West
because I played KonoSuba.
- It's huge.
- And every single time,
at least one person
or I should say at least
10 people asking me
every single time when
it's gonna be released,
in the West, internationally.
I know people like creators,
they said they're only making available
for Macao, Hong Kong,
Taiwan within this year,
but not thinking about
English translation yet.
- It's weird.
They tend to really focus on
Southeast Asian countries.
- It's because we spend the fucking cash.
(laughter)
What can I say?
- 'Cause I remember, I guess
that at a con in Singapore
and they were like sorts
of different booths
with all these companies
were selling new stuff
new merch and everything.
And an American con, it's only
the diehard fans would go up
and be like, "Give me one of everything."
"Give me the most expensive thing.
And it was just nuts to see so
many people just being like,
"Give me this, give me
this, give me this."
And people having five,
six bags worth of stuff.
And I'm like, "Jesus Christ,
"how much money do you have?"
Because the tickets aren't cheap either.
- I think it's just the culture there
that they just wanna collect them all
and collect and everything.
So combining that with Go-tcha,
that's the money printing machine.
- It was really funny as well
because I did a signing at
the Singapore convention
and the first guy came up to my table.
There was a line.
And the first guy came up to my table
and was like, "So how
much is for a signature?"
And I was like, "What do you mean?"
And he's like,
"We pay
"a signing fee, right?
"'Cause I wanna get this signed by you.
"How much is it?
And I'm like,
"Nothing, I'll just sign it for you."
And they just didn't understand.
Even the staff members were like, "What?"
- It's like, it's for free.
"But is it only the first one for free?"
"And then the second one I have to pay."
I'm like, "No, I'll sign like seven things
"if you want me to."
He's like, "What's the catch?
There must be a catch."
- They all relate to the precedent.
Like, "No, listen, he
said he was gonna do it.
"We've never had this before".
And apparently, I asked the
staff members afterwards
but apparently, I'm the
first guest at that con
ever who did a free signing.
And I'm like, how willing are people
to pay for things like this?
I'm like, I get it.
If it's a really famous
artist or a cosplayer
or a lot of their revenue
comes from con things.
But I'm like, I already make enough money
just doing my regular job.
I don't need to take fucking $5
from someone just to get
a little squiggle from me
on a piece of paper.
It's fine.
I'll just do it for free.
Because the thing is is
that I was already signing
people's stuff before my signing.
If people just found me and were like,
"Hey, can you sign this?"
I'm like, "Yeah, of course."
- I don't think my squiggle
was worth that much.
- It's not worth that much.
I came up with this
signature in two seconds.
It's not that valid.
- Yours is semi decent.
Mine's barely legible.
I just write C. (laughter)
I don't wanna think of something.
- Mine's like a child squiggles.
It's just that way.
- It's just nuts how Southeast Asian weebs
are just A, they're all fucking rich.
- They're ready to spend.
- Stop spending money
so that game companies
care about personal speakers.
- Or maybe the rest of
people have to spend more.
- The thing is I don't think they're rich.
I just think that this is what they spend
all their disposable income on.
- There is a larger audience
for it, unfortunately.
Not unfortunately, it's
great for the game companies.
- So Western weebs, if you
want your game to be localized
you better start spending some money.
Go grab your mom's credit card
and punch those numbers in.
- Rise up, gamers.
- Rise and grind, gamers.
- 'Cause there's so
many Go-tcha games here
that would just never get translated.
There's three JoJo Got-cha
games or something like that.
- They're pretty awful.
- Never been translated?
- No.
- What?
Even JoJo?
- Just because Go-tcha games
in general in the West,
I think it's like only
really a recent thing,
that it's like, "Oh yeah, cool.
"I could spend money on these."
- It's a new thing because the whole image
of mobile games in the
West was very terrible.
Everyone thinks of these
cheap knockoff games
or Raid Shadow Legends.
- Angry Birds or Candy Crush.
And it's like, "I'm not spending $2
"to get an extra life on Candy Crush.
"I'm sorry, I'm not that desperate.
- For very long time, all
mobile games were pretty
predatory I'd say in how they
try to make you spend money.
So I think there is that
notion of mobile game
equals you're trying to scam me.
So maybe there is a lot of that.
But hopefully, it'll change in the future
and we'll finally get that
KonoSuba localization.
- 'Cause that game looks fun.
- Yeah, it does.
- I enjoy KonoSuba doujinshi a lot too.
I don't usually go for doujinshi.
I don't really go for-
- Woman of culture here.
- -doujinshi adaptation.
I always go for edgy original stories.
- Who's the favorite?
- My favorite has always been Megumin.
But doujinshi wise, Aqua
is actually very useful.
(talk over each other) (laughter)
- Useful?
- She's been called useless.
She was fifth goddess.
- The only time she's useful
is in porn. (laughter)
- I'm gonna make it simple.
She can purify any liquid,
any happenings happens (laughs)
She can just purify it.
- Is this you like,
"Damn, I wish I had that
when I was doing it?"
None of this banana drink shit.
- None of this gluten-free cum online.
- Only the purest of juice for me.
- I'm a Darkness man.
I love Darkness.
You love Darkeness? I'm a Megumin.
- I know you are.
You're like, "10, I'll take that."
- That's not true.
- Beatrice, basically 10.
- Age is just a number.
- No. (laughter)
- Here we fucking go. Here we go.
- That's literally what people say
on the stand as they're being convicted,
Joey, come on, man.
- I didn't know.
- The UN is coming for, son.
- I can see just that one clipping gift
and we spread around now.
- Hi, Chris Hansen.
So as is tradition with
Trash Taste episodes
that have guests, we're
gonna get you to sign
a squishy so that we can put
it up on this wall right here.
- We say but Chris'
one is still down here.
- Chris didn't do a good job.
- This is his right here.
- I love you guys especially Jerry.
- Now, that's a signature.
- That's a signature right there.
Look at that squiggle, goddamn.
- Thank you very much for coming on.
It's been a pleasure
to have you as a guest.
In the meantime, here are
all the lovely patreons
who are here are supporting
the Trash Taste channel.
We definitely know that this episode
is gonna be demonitized as fuck.
- Look at these guys.
- Thank you very much.
- No ads on this one.
So if you'd like to support the show
and hopefully get some more cool guests
onto this show, then definitely yes.
Support our patreons.
- What?
- You're like, "I don't know what to say."
Please support patreons.
- You ever just start a sentence
and you don't know where it's gonna lead
but you just have to keep talking anyway?
(talk over each other)
- Do you wanna shout anything out?
- Please follow me on
social media, Twitter
Instagram, also in Twitch.
It's very new.
My YouTube channel isn't
my personal channel.
I'm just hired to be on the channel
I have nothing to do with editing
So stop telling me to
put English subtitles.
(laughter)
- Come on, you're an English teacher.
You can put English subtitles.
- I'm to busy with other things.
- We'll leave all those down
in the description wall,
definitely go check it out.
- Thank you so much for joining us.
- Thank you so much.
- I hope you had a good time here.
- Likewise.
- Anyway, that's been Trash Taste podcast.
I've been here with the boys
and the girl. (laughter)
It's nice to not have
to be in a sausage fest
of a podcast for once.
And we will see you guys later.
- [All] Bye.
- See you later.
- [All] See you later.